Hi, this is Joel Blackstock, and you're listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. Today I sat down with Dr. John Beebe and talked about clinical applications of the MBTI, or the Myers-Briggs Type Indicator. He is one of the foremost scholars on the Myers-Briggs Type Indicator in the world, and also the originator of the eight-function type model, or the the BB model, which lets you do some things with shadow types. The topic is very broad, and if you're completely unfamiliar with Myers-Briggs typology, this may not be the place to start. But if you're interested in the Myers-Briggs and wondering how to integrate it into your clinical practice or look for it in cases
你好，我是乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock），你正在收听的是Taproot Therapy Collective播客。今天我与约翰·比比（John Beebe）博士坐下来，探讨了MBTI（迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标）的临床应用。他是全球研究MBTI最顶尖的学者之一，也是八功能类型模型（即比比模型）的创始人，该模型能让你处理一些与阴影类型相关的问题。这个话题非常广泛，如果你对迈尔斯-布里格斯类型学完全不了解，这可能不是入门的最佳起点。但如果你对迈尔斯-布里格斯感兴趣，并想知道如何将其整合到临床实践中，或者如何在病例中观察它，那么这期播客可能很适合你。我现在就开始播放这段采访。那孩子需要治疗。躺在沙发上。前沿精神病学。是的，太棒了。我真的非常感谢你抽出时间。我们是一个规模较小的诊所，所以播客对我来说是一种有趣的方式，可以与那些鼓舞人心、具有开创性的人交流。但同时，你知道，你还要为这群治疗师做SEO（搜索引擎优化）。
with your patients, this may be the podcast for you. I will go ahead and roll that interview now. That boy needs therapy. Lie down on the couch. Frontier Psychiatry. Yeah, wonderful. And so I really, really appreciate your time. We're kind of a smaller clinic, and so the podcast is a fun way for me to talk to people that are inspirational and groundbreaking. But then also, you know, you do SEO for this group of therapists.
而且，你知道，我是听着你的讲座长大的，你和希尔曼（Hillman）的讲座。我为什么会有一个巨大的文件夹，里面装满了荣格分析师在七十年代到九十年代期间的讲座，还有唐纳德·科尔谢德（Donald Kohlshed）的资料。MBTI的内容对我来说非常迷人，因为我能看出它是如何运作的。但当我在这些会议中听到你和其他人交流时，我能感觉到他们实时进行这种计算是多么自然，而我却必须坐下来仔细研究。
And then, you know, I grew up listening to your talks, you and Hillman. And why I get this huge folder of Jungian analysts giving talks throughout the, you know, seventies through the nineties and Donald Kohlshed. And the MBTI stuff was really fascinating to me because I could, I could see how it worked. But when I hear you in these meetings with other people, I can tell how much more naturally, you know, they're doing this math in real time where I have to sit down and look at it.
这让我感觉自己像是在上高中，你知道，又在尝试做数学题。所以我在邮件里跟你说过，我感觉自己有点像萨列里（Salieri），能看出莫扎特有多伟大，但我自己却是个笨蛋，没有那种能力。所以，你知道，你得对我保持耐心，嗯，你知道，我对它的理解显然不如你，但这个目标……我只是在尝试用你与某人交谈时所用的任何技巧。
And it makes me feel like I'm in high school or something, you know, trying to do math again. So I told you in the email, I felt a little bit like you know salieri could see how great mozart was and i'm a dance but he didn't have the ability to do it so you know you'll have to be patient with um you know my understanding of it and is is obviously not as much as uh as much as yours uh But the goal of this... I'm just working with any skill you talk to someone
那个人已经实践了很长一段时间。嗯，我希望比比模型或其含义能被更多人了解。我认为许多正在研究人格风格和沟通分析的新晋创伤治疗师，他们正在使用其中的一些东西，你知道，如果能把这些语言带给他们会非常棒。所以我知道，你知道，我不想让你把所有内容都过一遍，但如果你能大概概述一下MBTI的理论，因为我认为它并没有被很好地理解。人们把它看作像星座运势之类的东西。嗯，我认为MBTI本身为我们制造的问题，在某种程度上，就像许多其他问题一样，是语言的问题，人们倾向于谈论人格类型。而人格是任何在职治疗师都必须感兴趣的东西。我之所以对类型感兴趣，除其他原因外，是因为我发现作为一名精神科医生，我必须治疗人格障碍。
who has been practicing it for a while. Well, I'd love the BB model or the implications of that to be better known. And I think a lot of the new trauma therapists who are looking at personality style and communication analysis, they're using some of these things, you know, and the language of that would be really neat to bring to them. So I know, you know, I don't want to make you walk through all of it, but if you could maybe just give like a little bit of overview of the theory of
换句话说，我们有神经症患者和精神病患者，然后我们有中间的所有人，结果发现那实际上就是我们所有人。但每个人的人格都有某种怪异之处，就像我们的指纹有怪异之处一样。其中一部分是某种正常的精神病理学倾向，在特定情况下会变得相当不正常。所以，把类型学变成一种人格理论是非常诱人的。因此，人们经常谈论人格类型。但荣格心里想的是什么呢？我认为他毕竟是发现这个模型的人，他在《心理类型》一书中给出的类型学模型，他在最后第10章非常清楚地表明他有八种功能类型。然后我们必须总是问：是什么的类型？它们不是人格的类型。它们是意识的类型。
the MBTI, because I think it's not very well understood. People see it as like a horoscope or something. Well, I think the problem even MBTI has created for us is, in a way, as so many other things are a problem of language, people have a tendency to talk about personality types. And personality is something that any working therapist has to be interested in. I got interested in types among other things because I found that I had to treat personality disorders as a psychiatrist.
它们就像物理学中所谓的“明亮粒子”，是我们所有人意识中的明亮粒子。唯一的问题是它们如何排列自己。荣格最初使用的是双功能模型。到了写《心理类型》时，他已经有了四功能模型，这是相当来之不易的。试着记住那段历史。这是一个试图研究他所称的“情结”（Complexes）的人，尽管这也不是原创的。当时已经有一个叫西奥多·齐恩（Theodor Ziehen）的人使用过这个术语，这在一定程度上建立在一位非常著名的老心理学家——冯特（Wundt，W-U-N-D-T）的基础上，他几乎确立了情结理论的基础。然后柏林精神科医生西奥多·齐恩开始谈论情结，这些被翻译为“情感基调情结”，它们实际上是“情感音调情结”。荣格认为这是关键，他当时是首席助理，他是一位年轻的精神科医生。他从医学院毕业后，在欧洲最伟大的精神科医生——苏黎世的尤金·布洛伊勒（Uwe Bleuler，B-L-E-U-L-E-R）手下担任首席助理，得到了一份很棒的工作。布洛伊勒非常有兴趣了解精神病是否存在可能的心理学解释。
In other words, we had the neurotics and the psychotics, and then we had all the people that were in the middle, and that turned out to be literally all of us. But everyone has some certain oddness to their personality, just as we have an oddness to our fingerprint. And part of that is a certain normal tendency to psychopathology, which under certain circumstances becomes quite abnormal. So it's very tempting to turn typology into a personality theory. And so very frequently, people talk about personality types. But what Jung had in mind, and I think he was, after all, the person who found this model that he created, the typology model that he gave in psychological types, where he eventually, at the very end in chapter 10, makes it very clear that he had eight function types. And then we have to always ask types of what? And they were not types of personality. They were types of consciousness.
所以荣格使用了齐恩的理论，并利用词语联想测试来识别情结，因为它们会导致反应时间延迟。他开始看到，是的，确实，人们确实有不同的情结。他开始谈论它们。他说有一个伤害情结。如果人们认为有人试图伤害他们，他们就会变得激动。有一个关于性的情结。有一个关于权力的情结，等等。所以他开始进行分析。
They were like, in physics, it's called the brilliant particles, the brilliant particles of consciousness in all of us. And the only question is how they arrange themselves. Now, Jung started with a two-function model. Then by the time he got to psychological types, he had a four-function model, which was quite hard-earned. Try to remember that history. Here's a man who is trying to study what he called, but even this wasn't original, complexes. There was already a man named Theodor Zeehan who had used this term, and that was partly being built on a very famous old psychologist
但后来他发现，试图通过缓慢的反应时间和对100个刺激词的奇怪反应来实验性地识别，尽管确实存在非常不同类型的人，但还是有那种走进咨询室的男人，他会像在军事演习中一样绝对立正，当然荣格当时穿着白大褂，用秒表和电流计来观察皮肤反应，即皮肤电反应。所以那个人会僵硬地立正，直视前方，并试图不给出那个词的准确联想。所以那是其中一种人。然后是另一种人，通常是女性，会说：“哦，看看那个。哦，你这可怜的人，你一定整天都得坐在这个闷热的房间里。哦，但你的测试颜色是美丽的鲑鱼色。多可爱啊，那一定让你感觉好多了。”所以他有了这种想法，即有两种类型的人。一种是他所说的不断评估的人，另一种是相当僵硬地试图思考的人。
named Wundt, W-U-N-D-T, who had pretty much established the basis of complex theory. And then Theodor Zeehan, Berlin psychiatrist starts talking about complexes and these were what got translated as feeling toned complexes they're really affect tone complexes and Jung was thought this was the key and his chief boiler he was a young psychiatrist. He got out of medical school. He got a great job as the chief assistant to the greatest psychiatrist in Europe, who was Uwe Bleuler, B-L-E-U-L-E-R, in Zurich. And Bleuler was very interested in learning if there was a possible psychology to the psychoses.
所以他有两种类型。他认为一种是外向的，一种是内向的，一种是情感的，一种是思考的，一种是男性的，一种是女性的。所以他把逻各斯（Logos）和厄洛斯（Eros）、思考和情感、外向和内向全都混在一起了。但他对此感到非常兴奋。所以这就是最初的两种类型。
So Jung used the Zien theory and used the word association test to identify complexes because they would be these delayed reaction times. And he began to see that, yes, indeed, people do have different complexes. And he started talking about them. And he said there's a complex of injury. People get excited if they think that someone is trying to hurt them. There's a complex around sexuality. There's a complex around power and so forth and so on. So he started to analyze.
然后当他深入研究时，他意识到还有其他的意识功能。所以从他第一次在人们定位任何事物的方式中发现类型问题开始，他花了很长时间，几乎用了12年，才有了四种意识功能。所以其中之一，直觉，这可能是他的主导功能，必须由别人为他创造，因为他很长一段时间里认为直觉甚至不是一种意识功能，他认为直觉是无意识。而且他认为——你知道，很长一段时间里他认为原型和直觉几乎是同一回事。所以他——最终到了1919年，他实际上有了这本书，他试图做的是帮助人们意识到我们确实有两个系统：
But then he found that trying to experimentally identify through slow reaction times and strange reactions to 100 stimulus words that despite that there were very different kinds of people there was the man that came into the consulting room and he would stand absolutely at attention as if on military drill of course jung was wearing a white coat and using a stopwatch and a galvanometer to see the skin responses, the electrical skin responses. And so the man would step stiffly to attention and look straight ahead and try not to give the exact association to the word. And so that was one kind of person. And then there was the other kind of person who was usually a woman would say, oh, look at that. Oh, you poor man, you've had to be sitting in this hot room all day long. And oh, but you have beautiful salmon color of the test. How lovely, that must make you feel better. So he had this idea that there were two types of people. One was what he called the person who was constantly evaluating and the other kind of person who was rather rigidly trying to think.
一个意识系统和一个无意识系统，而且我们有一种变得片面的倾向。所以他想看看我们是如何变得片面的。他说，这是因为我们优先使用某些意识，而这把其他意识置于了无意识之中。所以他觉得这非常有趣，并发展了这种心理类型理论。在最后，他意识到有四种功能类型和两种态度类型。所以四种功能类型是思考、情感、感觉和直觉，两种态度类型是外向和内向。现在，这确实流行起来了，第二种比第一种更流行。
And so he had two types. He thought one was extroverted and one was introverted and one was feeling and one was thinking and one was a man and one was a woman. So he had logos and eros and thinking and feeling and extroversion and introversion all mixed up with each other. But he got very excited about that. And so that was the original two types.
但被遗忘的是“是什么的类型”？他书的标题是《心理类型》。然后当它以英文出版时，英文译者H.G.贝恩斯（H.G. Baines）增加了一些或许更自命不凡的内容，他后来成为了英国第一位荣格分析师。但在很长一段时间里，他在苏黎世担任荣格的首席助理。
Then he realized as he got into it that there were other functions of consciousness. And so it took him almost from the time he first identified a type problem in the way people orient to anything, it took him quite a long time, almost 12 years before he had four functions of consciousness. So one of them, intuition, which was probably his dominant function, had to be made for him by someone else because he didn't think it was even a function of consciousness he thought intuition was the unconscious for a long time and he got and this you know for a long time he thought an archetype and intuition were virtually the same thing so he so finally by 1919 he's got a he's got actually this book and as he's and what he's trying to do is help people realize that we do have two systems,
H.G.贝恩斯加上了“个体化心理学”，即《心理类型或个体化心理学》。所以荣格觉得，并让那个标题出现在1923年英文版的书上，即人格本身的发展取决于为那些被推入无意识的意识功能腾出空间，但它们可以成为意识与无意识之间的意识接入点。所以有很多强调，过去也有很多强调，关于所谓的“劣势功能”，因为那是通往无意识的接入点。然后有一个想法，嗯，因为那是通往无意识的接入点，它是一种通往无意识的桥梁。
a conscious and an unconscious, and we have a tendency to become one-sided. So he then wanted to see how we become one-sided. And he said, it's because we use some consciousnesses preferentially, and that puts other consciousnesses as it were in the unconscious. And so he found that very interesting, and he developed this theory of psychological types. And toward the end, he realized that there are four function types and two attitude types. So the four function types were thinking, feeling, sensation, and intuition, and two attitude types, extrovert and introvert. Now, that really caught on, the second more than the first.
这在荣格对类型的后期发展中很早就出现了，即那将是劣势功能。就我而言，作为一个狂热的外向直觉者，那个劣势功能是内向感觉功能。你只需要观察我，跟着我，看我把所有东西都放错地方，就会发现我确实有劣势的内向感觉。尽管经过多年的自我意识和对这个问题的研究，它仍然保持在低位和劣势。所以我们有约翰·比比（John Beebe）这样一个外向直觉意识，喜欢捕捉突发的事物，特别是在其他人身上发生的事情。因此，我喜欢并热衷于做心理治疗，因为事情总是在那里涌现。这就是心理治疗，一系列涌现的现象，
But what got lost is types of what? The title of his book was Psychological Types. And then when it was published in English, something perhaps more pretentious was added by the English translator H.G. Baines, who later became the first Jungian analyst in England. But for a long time, he was in Zurich as a kind of chief associate or chief assistant to
弗洛伊德分析师会称之为洞察力。但那种持续涌现的意识对我来说非常令人兴奋。它就像园丁看着花朵绽放一样美丽。所以我仍然像我在19岁生日那天决定成为精神科医生时一样热爱它。所以我现在已经从事这项工作，追求这条道路很长很长时间了。我发现荣格与精神科医生能做的事情非常兼容。
Jung. And H.G. Baines added the psychology of individuation, psychological types or the psychology of individuation. So Jung felt that and let that title go on his book when it got published in English in 1923, that the development of personality itself depended upon making room for functions of consciousness that were more pushed down into the unconscious, but could become conscious access points between conscious and unconscious. So there's a lot of emphasis, and was a lot of emphasis, on the so-called inferior function, because that was the access point to the unconscious. And then there was an idea that, well, because that was the access point to the unconscious. And then there was an idea that, well, if it's an access point to the unconscious, it's a kind of bridge
现在已经没有多少精神科医生对心理治疗感兴趣了，至少在阿尔梅达（Almeida）不是这样。他们在某种程度上已经远离了，尽管我认为他们所有人都对把心理治疗作为他们的真正工作感到内疚。但当然，与患者接触、理解患者并观察正在涌现的东西是每一位精神科医生的工作。所以荣格提出了这个非常重要的观点，即劣势功能和优势功能一样，都是意识的功能，而不是人的类型。
to the unconscious. And this came up quite early for Jung in the late development of type, that that would be that inferior function in myself being being a rabid, extroverted, intuitive, that inferior function is an introverted sensation function. You just have to watch me, follow me around as I misplace everything to see that I really do have inferior introverted sensation, despite years of self-awareness and work on the problem, it stays low and inferior. So we have in John Beebe an extroverted intuitive consciousness that loves to pick up on emergent things, particularly in what's happening with other people. Hence, I enjoy and am passionately interested in doing psychotherapy where things emerge all the time. That's what psychotherapy is, a set of emergent phenomena
但所有的类型都是情结，就像他最初研究情结时所学到的那样。他称它们为类型情结、功能情结或态度情结。如今，多亏了理查德·汤普森（Richard Thompson），我们可以称它们为“功能态度”。有些人更愿意称它们为“态度功能”。只要你同时理解态度和功能，并意识到它们是同一回事，这其实并不重要。所以我们从技术上知道
that Freudian analysts would call it insights. But that constant emergence of awareness is very exciting to me. It's as beautiful as to a gardener watching flowers bloom. And so I am still as in love with it as I was when I decided to be a psychiatrist for sure on my 19th birthday. And so I've been at this now, pursuing this path for a very, very long time. And I found Jung very compatible with what a psychiatrist
没有独立存在的思考、情感、感觉或直觉。它只有外向或内向的思考、情感、感觉或直觉。但再说一次，这些是什么？它们是意识的情结。这确实是荣格的本质。荣格最初作为一名精神科医生，是为了寻找无意识的情结。但他最终了解到，也存在意识的情结。
who's interested in psychotherapy can do. There aren't a ton of psychiatrists interested in psychotherapy anymore, at least not in Almeida. They've moved away to some degree, although all of them, I think they've become guilty about doing psychotherapy as in their real work. But of course, it is every psychiatrist's work to try to engage with the patient, understand the patient, and see what's emerging. So Jung came up with this very important idea that the inferior function, like the superior function, are both functions of consciousness, not types of people.
他很早就了解到，荣格总是有一种奇妙的能力，能看到事物的要点，看到事物的原因。所以任何接触过精神病理学的人，处理过——这些天，每个人都对创伤情结感兴趣，我猜你在这方面做了很多工作，但情结有很多很多种。嗯，我的意思是，我认为MBTI虽然有——你知道，有大写的T创伤，但也有某种平等化的东西，你知道，有八种思考模式。嗯，这就是我要说的，我们都不擅长以某种方式思考。
But all types are complexes, just as that original work he was doing on complexes taught him. He called them type complexes or function complexes or attitude complexes. These days, thanks to Richard Thompson, we can speak of them as function attitudes. Some people would rather call them attitude functions. It doesn't really matter as long as you get both attitude and function and realize they're the same thing. So we know technically
我们会有一个情结。完全正确，完全正确，乔尔，当你以某种方式思考时。现在，让我们去……当你发展出一个似乎是无意识障碍的情结时，拉丁语中“情结”的意思是
that there's no thinking, feeling, sensation, intuition in and of itself. It only is extroverted or introverted thinking, feeling, sensation or intuition. But again, what are these? And these are complexes of consciousness. That was really what Jung was. Jung was starting as a psychiatrist to find the complexes of the unconscious. But what he finally learned is that there are also complexes of consciousness.
“结”，它通常采取一种“不”的形式，因为它是如此敏感，以至于你无法做到，比如怯场。例如，我不会——我的意思是，我认识一些深爱的人，他们宁愿不结婚，因为想到必须站在教堂里的一群人面前宣读誓言，这让他们感到非常恐惧。所以现在我们认为情结是某种阻碍我们并阻止我们做某事的东西。但在每个情结的核心，正如每个与它打交道的人所知，是情结知道一些事情。情结有一个目的。它有存在的理由。是荣格看到了它的要点，不安的要点，它的要点。换句话说，假设那个人不想结婚，因为要结婚，你必须站在观众面前。是的，这些天，同一个人很可能会服用普萘洛尔（Propranolol），这样他们就能熬过婚礼仪式。
He did learn early that every, it was always Jung's wonderful ability to see the point of things, to see why, the why of things. So anyone who's been around psychopathology, working with, these days, everyone is interested in traumatic complexes i gather you've done a lot of work with that but there are many many kinds of complexes well i mean i think the mbti though there's you know there's trauma with a capital t but also there's something equalizing about that that you know there's eight modes of thinking well that's where i'm getting is that and we're all bad at thinking a certain way.
但如果这个情结是在告诉那个人，婚姻——不是面对观众的恐惧，而是给观众他们想要的东西的恐惧：一个快乐的新娘，而她实际上对婚姻本身深感矛盾。不一定是关于她要嫁的那个男人，而是关于这种制度。我有时觉得，如果我们有一个完全诚实的社会，就像一包香烟一样，结婚证上会写着：警告，此仪式可能对你的心理健康有害。你能想象如果我们真的那样说吗？没有人会那样说。那会扫了爱、浪漫、婚姻和家庭等等的兴。但事实上，在那位不情愿的新娘的怯场背后，可能有很多对仪式本身的担忧，
We'll have a complex. Exactly, exactly, Joel, when you're thinking a certain way. Now, let's go to... When you develop a complex that seems to be an unconscious hang-up, the Latin word for complex means
而不是因为仪式和演讲，而是因为它的内涵，以及婚姻的所有历史和婚姻的所有局限性，这些都可以被有益地探索。然后你会发现，嗯，这个情结很聪明。这个情结知道一些事情。这并不意味着她永远不应该结婚。这并不意味着情结是唯一的东西，但一个人需要为它腾出空间。坦率地说，我认为人们在探索完所有他们不应该结婚的理由之前，不应该结婚，如果你明白我的意思的话。
not, and it often takes the form of an not something that because it's so touchy you you can't do it like stage fright for example like i will not i mean and i know people who deeply in love would rather not get married because the thought of having to stand in front of an audience of people in the church and say the vows terrifies them so much. So now we think of complexes as something hanging us up and keeping us from doing something. But at the heart of every complex, as everyone who works with it, is that the complex knows something. The complex has a purpose. It has a reason for being. It was Jung who saw point of it, the point of the upset, the point of it. In other words, let's say the person who doesn't want to get married because to get married, you have to stand in front of an audience. Yes, these days, that same person was likely to take propanolol so they can get through the wedding ceremony.
这就是荣格发现我们任何情结的目的性的地方。所以目的在于意识。现在，随着他对比意识越来越感兴趣，他也对比类型越来越感兴趣。这就是为什么每个人都在期待1921年的那本书，嗯，荣格已经与弗洛伊德分道扬镳了，现在我们终于要得到荣格的无意识理论了，
But what about the possibility that the complex is telling the person that marriage not to put the fear of facing the audience but the fear of giving the audience what it wants a happy bride when she's actually deeply ambivalent about marriage itself not necessarily about the man she's marrying but about the institution i have sometimes felt that if we had a completely honest society, just like a pack of cigarettes, the marriage license would say, warning, this ceremony could be harmful to your mental health. Can you imagine if we actually said that? No one would ever say that. It would rain on the complete parade of love, romance, and marriage, and families, and so forth. But in fact, behind that reluctant bride's stage fright might be a lot of concern about the ceremony itself,
与弗洛伊德的相对立。然后他出版了这本《心理类型》。他有智慧在进一步探索意识通过这些无意识情结隐藏的所有异常方式之前，先看看正常的意识是什么样的。所以他是在无意识情结的基础上增加了意识情结。他确实发现我们所有人都有八种这样的情结。这些就是八种意识功能类型。而我特别是在这项工作的基础上建立了自己的理论。在我之前，苏黎世有荣格派学者。有一个叫迈耶（Meyer）的男人，还有一个叫玛丽-路易丝·冯·弗朗茨（Marie-Louise von Franz）的女人。她写了这本了不起的书或专著，你可以说是关于劣势功能的，它与詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）关于情感功能的同样了不起的作品相配。那本书特别教会了我，从八种劣势功能、八种劣势意识类型的角度，以及它对人格和功能的影响，去思考劣势功能能走多远。所以这是意识对人格的影响，而不是人格的类型，类型学对人格的影响成了我的目标，看看你能走多远
and not because of the ceremony and the speech, but because of what it connotes and all the history of marriage and all of the limitations of marriage, that those could be explored profitably. And then you discover, well, the complex was smart. The complex knew something. That doesn't mean that she should never get married. It doesn't mean the complex is the only thing, but one needs to make room for that. And frankly, I think people shouldn't marry until they've explored all the things, all the reasons why they shouldn't marry, if you see what I mean.
作为一名精神科医生，认真对待不同类型的意识，给它们发言权，给它们空间去观察，然后看看还剩下什么病理，以及你自己可能在多大程度上将那个人的完全正常的意识病理化了，或者他们在多大程度上将自己的意识病理化了，因为在他们的家庭、文化、国家、学校或企业中，它没有被承认为一种有效的意识，而是已经被当作替罪羊，被当作你不应该进入的东西来对待。所以对我来说，这一切都是关于通过理解我们每个人体内的意识储备，你能走多远。为了做到这一点，你知道，我把它看得和音乐学院教授视唱练耳一样严肃，你必须教学生do, re, mi, fa, sol, la, ti, do。
And that's where Jung found the purposiveness of any of our complexes. So in the purpose is consciousness. Now, as he got more interested in consciousness, he also got more interested in types. And that's why the 1921 book that everyone was expecting, well, Jung has separated from Freud, and now we're going to get Jung's theory of the unconscious at last,
所以在我看来，教授八种意识功能是开始进入人格音乐的全部意义所在，这是意识人格可以表现出来的。否则，就像——没有意识，类型学的意识层面，心灵会有点像噪音。就像有人在钢琴上乱敲，发出不和谐的声音。但意识是一件美丽的事情，它可以为人格提供服务。
as opposed to Freud's. And then he comes out with this book, Psychological Types. And he had the wisdom to try to see what normal consciousness is like before he went any further with the exploration of all the abnormal ways in which consciousness hides through these unconscious complexes. And so he was adding to the unconscious complexes the conscious complexes. And he found indeed that all of us have eight of these. And these are the eight function types of consciousness. And it's really on that work that I particularly have built. And there were Jungians before me in
八个音符为西方音乐提供了什么，你从中得到了莫扎特和贝多芬，我的意思是，这太棒了。所以这就是——我毕生的工作是尝试看看我们能用意识做什么，以及当我们也理解它们是通往荣格所谈论的这种意识的途径时，我们的情结会发生什么。这就是我所做的。把类型看作意识的类型，把意识的类型看作明亮的粒子，它们有功能：思考、情感、感觉、直觉，但它们也有态度：外向或内向。所以你得到了意识的功能态度，并尝试学习它们是如何排列自己的，它们本质上是什么，以及它们在心灵中发生发展的空间对它们如何表达自己有什么影响。
Zurich. There was a man named Meyer and also a woman named Marie-Louise von Franz. And she wrote this amazing book or monograph, you could say, on the inferior function that was paired with an equally amazing work by James Hillman on the feeling function. That book particularly taught me how far you could go with thinking about, in her case, the inferior function from the standpoint of eight types of inferior function, eight types of inferior consciousness, and what its effect was on personality and on functioning. So it's the effect of consciousness on personality rather than types of personality the effects of typology on personality became my uh my goal and to see how far you could get
这就是我的全部工作。我的模型只是这种表达，我的书《能量与模式》（Energies and Patterns）有15章，就像关于这个主题的15盏灯，你可以按任何顺序阅读它们。大多数人读他们喜欢的章节，然后去读另一章，你可以读两遍这本书，你可以倒着读，它——它只是一系列关于当你那样思考时会发生什么的灯，当你根据不同人的意识是什么以及它是如何分布的来思考时。所以八功能模型是一个自组织系统，
as a psychiatrist by taking the different types of consciousness seriously, giving them their say, giving them room to see, and then see what pathology is left and how much you yourself may have pathologized perfectly normal consciousness in the person or how much they may have pathologized their own consciousness because in their family or culture or nation or school or business, it wasn't recognized as a valid consciousness, but was already scapegoated and treated as something you don't get into. And so for me, it's all been about how far you can get by understanding the reservoir of consciousness in each of us. And so to do that, you know, I take it as seriously as someone teaching in a music school and a conservatory of music would teach solfege where you have to teach the students do, re, mi, fa, sol, la, ti, do.
一种表现模式，一种相当美丽的东西，那就是意识。理想情况下，一种相当美丽的东西，那就是意识。理想情况下，好的心理治疗会促进它。所以致力于某人被困住的特定事物，或特定的情结，特定的伤害，或特定的问题。
And so it seems to me that teaching the eight functions of consciousness is the whole point of starting to get into the music of of of of of the personality which is the consciousness personality can evince otherwise the like like without consciousness uh the conscious aspect of the typology the psyche would be sort of like a noise. It would be like someone banging at a piano and producing discordant sounds. But consciousness is a beautiful thing and it can provide for personality.
我曾与唐纳德·桑德（Donald Sonder）合著过关于情结的书，《荣格分析》（Jungian Analysis）第二卷。或者，我不应该说卷，我应该说在《荣格分析》的第二版中，它最初是由默里·斯坦（Murray Stein）在1981年制作的。然后在1995年有了第二版，唐纳德·桑德（Sander, S-A-N-D-E-R-N-I）和默里·斯坦邀请我为第一卷、第一版写了《精神病理学与分析》，
What the eight notes and provided for the Western music, you getzart and beethoven out of it i mean it's wonderful so that's what so my life's work is to try to see what we can do with with consciousness and what happens to our complexes when we also understand that they're en route to this very consciousness young is talking about. So that's what I've done. Thinking of the types as types of consciousness, thinking of the types of consciousness as brilliant particles and that they have functions, thinking, feeling, sensation, intuition, but they also have attitudes, extroverted or introverted. So you get the function attitudes of consciousness and to try to learn how they arrange themselves, what they are intrinsically and what the place in the psyche in which they happen to develop does to how they express themselves.
我为唐和我修改了它。我为默里书的第二版做了第二版本的编辑修订。那是我希望人们阅读和购买的版本，乔尔，我很高兴与你分享一份，因为在那里我试图展示类型学是如何融入精神病理学的。我明确地建立了情结理论与类型学之间的联系
That's been my entire work. My model is just an expression of that and there's 15 chapters of my book energies and patterns psychological type are like 15 lights on the subject you could read them in any order most people read read a chapter they like and go to another and you can read the book twice you can read it backwards it it will it's just a, just a series of lights on the subject of what happens when you think that way, when you think in terms of what consciousness is in different people and how it's distributed. And so the eight function model is a self organizing system,
在那里。我正在使用我在那里开发的八功能态度模型来做到这一点。所以我希望你知道，作为一名精神科医生，我把我作为精神科医生学到的一切都放在了那里。我确实在1975年合著了一本名为《精神治疗：危机诊所与咨询》（Psychiatric Treatment Crisis Clinic and Consultation）的书，在
a pattern of, of manifestation of a rather beautiful thing, which is consciousness. And ideally a rather beautiful thing, which is consciousness. And ideally, a good psychotherapy fosters it. And so working on a particular thing that someone is hung up on, or a particular complex, a particular injury, or a particular issue.
1995年，我写了一篇关于精神病理学与分析的荣格文章。所以你会在那里准确地看到我作为精神科医生与有情结的患者（这些情结确实给他们带来了很多麻烦）的工作是如何受到类型理论启发的，以及类型理论如何解释当意识功能不支持他们的意识，反而破坏它时，人们身上会发生什么。所以它涉及到了荣格心理学中阴影的整个问题，以及阴影的类型如何真正困扰我们。所以这就是我建立那种联系的地方。我向任何想看到联系的人推荐它
And I have written about complexes with Donald Sonder, the book Jungian Analysis, Volume 2. Rather, I shouldn't say volume, I should say in the second edition of Jungian Analysis, which was originally produced in 1981 by Murray Stein. And then in 1995, had a second edition, and Donald Sander, S-A-N-D-E-R-N-I, and Murray Stein's invitation for the first volume, first edition, had written Psychopathology and Analysis,
直接与临床工作联系起来。它隐含在我所有的写作中，但它在那里非常明确地作为一种效果呈现出来，即用于临床工作的情结理论，其中类型学占很大比重。所以我建议任何真正有兴趣研究我的工作与心理治疗师处理困难事物的日常实践之间的联系的人。我想你会看到我是如何建立这种联系的。是的，我读过很多你的书
and I revised it for Don and me. I did the editorial revision of the second version for the second edition of Murray's book. That's the one I hope people will read and buy, and I'm happy to share with you a copy of it, Joel, because there I try to show how typology figures into psychopathology. And I make the link explicitly between complex theory
和很多马克·亨辛格（Mark Hunsinger）的书。你说的是C.A.迈耶（C.A. Meyer）做过类型学研究吗？C.A.迈耶，没错。在他写的一本叫《人格》（Personality）的书里，或者你有没有遇到过卡伦·霍妮（Karen Horney）——你知道依恋风格，我不知道你是否见过那些。我认为卡伦·霍妮是一个了不起的人物，答案是据我所知，卡伦·霍妮在柏林接受过分析，我想是和卡尔·亚伯拉罕（Carl Abraham）一起。但他是一位精神科医生，在弗洛伊德和荣格分裂后，他几乎接管了荣格所持有的角色，即弗洛伊德最信任的人。精神分析训练，在精神分析中，我该怎么说呢？正统是最简单的说法，它在1950年代的纽约精神病学中占据统治地位。
and typology in there. And I'm using the eight-function attitude model that I've developed there to do that. So I'd like you to know that's where I put as a psychiatrist everything I learned as a psychiatrist and I did co-author a book called Psychiatric Treatment Crisis Clinic and Consultation in 1975 and in
当卡伦·霍妮来到美国时，她强烈地背离了亚伯拉罕关于精神分析应该如何实践及其理论基础的极其僵化的模型。所以她成为了所谓的“新弗洛伊德主义者”。所以我知道她的工作是因为我有机会，一位中国女性翻译了她关于冲突的书。我想称它为
1995 I did a Jungian piece on psychopathology and analysis. So there you'll see precisely how my work as a psychiatrist with patients with complexes that were really causing them lots of trouble is informed by type theory and how a type theory can explain some of what happens to people when functions of consciousness do not support their consciousness, but actually undermine it. So it gets into the entire question of the shadow in Jungian psychology and how the types of the shadow can really bedevil us. And so that's where I made that connection. And I recommend that to anyone who wants to see the link
《我们的神经症冲突》，但那不是她的书名。让我看看她的书名是什么。你可能知道这本书。这真是一本了不起的书。这本书应该被任何人阅读，中国有人翻译了这本书
to clinical work directly. It's implied in all my writing, but it's very explicitly laid out there as an effect, complex theory for clinical work in which typology figures largely. So that I advise anyone who's really interested in studying my work as it's linking to the daily practice of psychotherapist working with difficult things. I think you'll see how I make the link. Yeah, I've read a lot of yours
我为它写了序言，《我们的内心冲突》（Our Inner Conflicts），那本书最终会出版，但我记得这是在1945年出版的。感觉就像你和某人一起在咨询室里进行治疗，因为人们带着一整套防御机制和自我组织来到治疗中，他们几乎是来找你克服和看透这些的。所以你可能比我做了更多的工作，
and a lot of Mark Hunsinger's books. Was that C.A. Meyer, you said, did work with typology? C.A. Meyer, that's right. It's in a book called Personality that he wrote or did you ever encounter karen horn eyes um you know attachment styles i don't know if you ever saw those i think karen horn eye is a wonderful figure and the answer is as far as I know, Karen Horney was an analysis in Berlin, I guess, with Carl Abraham. But he was a psychiatrist who pretty much after Freud and Jung split took over the role that Jung had held of the trusted, that Freud most trusted. psychoanalytic training in the psychoanalytic, how can I put it? Orthodoxy is the simplest way to say it that was reigning in New York psychiatry in the 1950s.
我不知道她关于依恋风格的具体工作。但当我读这本书时，我觉得这个女人曾在我办公室里。她是一位了不起的作家。我的意思是，她知道我们每天处理什么。而且以一种方式，无论你是弗洛伊德派还是荣格派，我认为你都能受益，或者其他人也能。有很多阿德勒派，无论他们是否知道，许多人看到了我们在谈论什么。如果你看到了我们在谈论什么，多么令人惊奇，既是一个虚假的自我，
When Karen Horney came to America, she moved strongly away from Abraham's extremely rigid model of psychoanalysis should be practiced and what its theoretical base was. And so she became what was called a neo-Freudian. So the work I know of her is because I had a chance, a woman in China translated her book on conflicts. I want to call it,
她确实在描述它，但也有巨大的内部压力要摆脱那个虚假的自我，而可能出现的真实自我，都可以从类型学上理解。当它发生时，这是一个奇迹。在这本书中，她更擅长展示当你不在那里时它看起来是什么样子，而不是当你开始在那里时它看起来是什么样子。类型学允许我更清楚地说出防御组织看起来是什么样子，
Our Neurotic Conflicts, but that's not her title. Let me look and see what her title is. You may know this book. It's just wonderful book. This book should be read by anyone someone in China translated this
特别是当阴影情结真正处于阴影中，即无意识时，以及当有一种真实的自我组织整合时它看起来是什么样子。所以她所做的是讲述在它发生之前所有不发生的方式，这是每个治疗师都必须处理的问题。最后一章是《神经症冲突》的结论。但她展示的事情之一是外向和内向是如何被防御性地使用的。所以她有一章叫“走向他人”。她有一章叫“远离他人”。她还有一章叫“对抗他人”。
and I wrote a forward to it our inner conflicts that book is coming out eventually but this was published as I recall, in 1945. feel like you're right in the consulting room with someone coming to therapy as people come to therapy with a whole set of defenses and a self-organization, which almost they've come to you to get over and to see through. So you probably have done much more work than I,
那是三种风格，《神经症与人的成长》。她谈到了童年的起源。所有这些都可以被理解为当具有外向或内向态度的意识类型被用作
and I don't know her specific work on attachment styles. But when I read this book, I felt this woman has been in my office. She's a remarkable writer. I mean, she knows what we deal with every day. And in a way that, and whether you're Freudian or Jungian, I think you could benefit or anybody else. There are plenty of Adlerians, whether they know it or not, and many see what we're talking about. And if you see what we're talking about, how amazing that both a false self,
自我的防御，而不是作为自我的实际流露和实现，而不是作为自我的实际流露和实现。所以我对阴影情结的工作，以及关于四种人格类型、四种功能类型、四种功能态度、构成我们主导、辅助、第三和劣势功能的人格，以及一种奇妙的诱人的完整感，
which he's really describing, but also the great internal pressure to get out of that false self and the true self that might emerge can be understood typologically. And what a miracle it is when it happens. In this book, she's more good at showing what it looks like when you're not there as to what it looks like when you start to be there. The typology allows me to say more
四种功能给我们的。但正是因为那种意识分化的程度，我们有同样的四种功能以相反的态度使用，创造了无意识的情结，除非我们使它们有意识。所以像其他分析师一样，我一直在处理一位荣格分析师所说的“自我的防御”。我试图帮助那个人减少被自我防御所占据，并能够通过做他们自己来更充分地防御自己，通过能够使用
clearly what the defensive organization looks like, particularly when the shadow complexes are truly in shadow, that is unconscious, and what it looks like when there's a kind of integration of an authentic self-organization. So what she does is tell all the ways in which that doesn't happen before it does happen, which is what every therapist has to deal with. The final chapter is conclusion of neurotic conflicts. But one of the things she shows is how both extroversion and introversion are used defensively. So she has a chapter called moving toward people. And she has a chapter called moving away from people. She also has a chapter called moving against people.
他们天生和自然的四种意识功能，并充分意识到他们遗漏的一切，这样情结就不必不断地从内部进行补偿来限制他们。这几乎就像我们的神经症往往像是一条拴在狗身上的皮带，那只狗想带着它认为正确的事情跑掉。神经症或创造神经症的阴影功能正试图在某种程度上限制我们，这样我们就不会脱轨。当你使它更有意识，并且你实际上看到了无意识中所有的意识并倾听
Those are the three styles, neurosis and human growth. She talks about the origin in childhood. All of those could be understood as what happens when types of consciousness with extroverted or introverted attitudes are used as
它时，通常症状开始消失，并且有一种巨大的完整感，这不是四种功能的诱惑，而是四种意识功能和四种阴影的平衡完整感，我们注意这一点，这样我们就不会变得太不平衡。现在，我不知道我是否已经做得太片面了，约翰·比比（John Beebe）带着他的外向直觉和内向思考，以及他的第三外向情感和内向思考，以及他的第三外向情感和劣势内向感觉。但至少我意识到还有另一个世界
defenses of the self rather than as actual emanations and realizations of the self rather than as actual emanations and realizations of the self. And so what I feel my work on shadow complexes, and on the four, we have four types of personality for function types for function attitudes, personality that constitute our dominant, auxiliary, tertiary, and inferior function, and a kind of marvelously seductive sense of wholeness,
属于那些拥有主导内向直觉，或拥有辅助外向思考，或拥有第三内向情感，或拥有劣势外向感觉的人。那另一个人格也在我身上。如果我太沉迷于做我所谓的自我，而遗漏了太多东西，它会给我带来麻烦。至少我意识到了这一点。
which four gives us. But just because of that degree of differentiation of consciousness, we have those same four functions used with the opposite attitude, creating complexes of the unconscious, unless we make them conscious. So that like every other analyst, I'm dealing all the time with what one Jungian analyst called defenses of the self. And I'm trying to help the person be less possessed by defenses of the self, and more adequately able to defend themselves by being themselves by being able to use
我记得你很久以前做过一个关于你的梦改变的讲座。有一个由一对中国夫妇拥有的洗衣店，你会去那里并做梦。一家洗衣店，一家洗衣店，不是自助洗衣店。一家真正的洗衣店，她实际上在那里接收衣物，清洗它，并折叠它。这非常重要。她代表了我的内向感觉。她是一位名叫佩吉·吴（Peggy Wu）的中国女性，我在现实生活中住过，
their native and natural four functions of consciousness, with full awareness of everything they leave out so that the complexes don't have to constantly compensate from within to restrain them it's almost like our neuroses tend to be like a leash on the dog that wants to run off with it's what it thinks is the right thing to do. The neurosis or the shadow functions that create the neurosis are trying to down boy, restrain us to some degree so that we don't go off the rails. When you make that more conscious and you actually see all the consciousness that's in the unconscious and listen
他们与生俱来的四种意识功能，并充分意识到他们所遗漏的一切，这样情结就不必不断地从内部进行补偿来约束他们。这几乎就像我们的神经症倾向于成为拴住那只想要跑掉的狗的皮带，因为它认为那是正确的事情。神经症或创造神经症的阴影功能试图在某种程度上约束我们，让我们冷静下来，以免我们脱轨。当你让这一切变得更加清醒，并且真正看到潜意识中所有的意识并倾听时，
to it usually the symptoms start to go away and there's a great feeling of wholeness that is not seductive of four but it's the it's the it's the balanced wholeness of four conscious functions and four shadows to that that we heed so that we don't just get too unbalanced. Now, I don't know how much I've done just already to be one-sidedly John Beebe with his extroverted intuition and introverted thinking and his tertiary extroverted feeling and introverted thinking and is tertiary extroverted feeling as inferior introverted sensation. But at least I'm aware that there's another world
通常症状就会开始消失，并且会产生一种巨大的完整感，这种完整感不是对四的诱惑，而是四种意识功能和四种阴影功能的平衡完整，我们注意这些，这样我们就不会变得太不平衡。现在，我不知道我已经做了多少工作来单方面地成为约翰·比比（John Beebe），拥有他的外倾直觉和内倾思考，以及他的第三功能外倾情感和内倾思考，还有作为劣势功能的内倾感觉。但至少我意识到还有另一个世界，
that belongs to people who have dominant introverted intuition or that have auxiliary extroverted thinking or that have tertiary introverted feeling or that have inferior extroverted sensation. And that other personality is there too in me. And it's going to give me troubles if I get too caught up in being my supposed self and leave too much of that out. At least I'm aware of it.
属于那些拥有主导内倾直觉、辅助外倾思考、第三功能内倾情感或劣势外倾感觉的人。那另一个人格也存在于我身上。如果我太沉迷于所谓的自我，而忽略了太多那部分，它就会给我带来麻烦。至少我意识到了这一点。
I remember you had a talk that I listened to a long time ago about your dream changing. There was a laundromat owned by a Chinese couple that you would visit and dream. A laundrette, a laundrette, not a laundromat. A real laundrette where she actually was there receiving the laundry, washing it, and folding it. That was very important. She represented my introverted sensation. She was a Chinese woman named Peggy Wu, who I lived in real life,
我记得很久以前我听过你的一次谈话，关于你的梦境发生了变化。有一家由一对中国夫妇经营的洗衣店，你会去那里并做梦。一家洗衣店，一家洗衣店，不是自助洗衣店。一家真正的洗衣店，她实际上在那里接收衣物、清洗并折叠。这非常重要。她代表了我的内倾感觉。她是一位名叫佩吉·吴（Peggy Wu）的中国女性，我在现实生活中认识她，
three blocks from the old Victorian I was living in in San Francisco. And for various reasons that say everything about my inferior function, I had a nice house, but I didn't have laundry facilities in it. So I took my laundry. I loved taking my laundry because she would bring it back to me in order. I mean, everything would be very neatly packaged. And
离我当时在旧金山住的那栋维多利亚式老房子只有三个街区。由于种种原因，这些原因充分说明了我劣势功能的表现，我虽然有一栋不错的房子，但里面没有洗衣设施。所以我去洗衣服。我喜欢去洗衣服，因为她会把洗好的衣服整理好交给我。我的意思是，每一件衣服都会被非常整齐地打包好。而且
in San Francisco, there are a lot of Asian people and that have coming to America as immigrants, restaurants and laundries were very, very popular and they're very, very relatively inexpensive. So it probably wasn't cost effective and a more practical person would put in a washer and dryer as I now have and I'm my own laundry person now. But she was a critical figure for me because things and objects and were a perfect chaos for this extroverted intuitive man I mean he was just a constant creator of what could be called litter and mess and the idea of taking my laundry to her and having it come back neatly packaged and all folded just for me there was something the only word that you can use is Jung's word numinous n-u-m-i-n-o-u-s which he got from a book called the idea of the holy it has the nod of the god
在旧金山，有很多作为移民来到美国的亚洲人，餐馆和洗衣店非常非常受欢迎，而且相对来说非常便宜。所以这可能并不划算，一个更务实的人会安装洗衣机和烘干机，我现在就有了，我自己就是自己的洗衣工。但她对我来说是一个关键人物，因为对于这个外倾直觉型的人来说，事物和物体简直是一团混乱。我的意思是，他简直就是所谓的垃圾和混乱的持续制造者。而把衣服拿给她，让她把衣服整齐地打包、折叠好交给我，这种感觉，唯一能用的词就是荣格所说的“神圣的”（numinous），这个词他取自一本叫《神圣的观念》的书，它带有上帝的旨意。
to it there's something sacred about it. So I found that whole thing of taking my laundry to Peggy Wu. But when I dreamed about her, she was a poor woman. And she was bitter and alone in her room because she didn't have anything. She had a husband who wasn't bringing his money home and he was presumably off gambling or something and doing
它有一种神圣感。所以我发现把衣服送到吴佩吉（Peggy Wu）那里去这件事本身就很有意义。但当我梦到她时，她是一个贫穷的女人。她很痛苦，独自待在房间里，因为她一无所有。她有一个丈夫，他不把钱拿回家，大概是去赌博什么的，而且
and just not being around and so there wasn't even any furniture and she was just alone in a room and she looked unhappy and it was an analysis with a woman at that time. I can say her name, her name was Elizabeth Osterman, O-S-T-E-R-M-A-N and she had once met Jung. She was an American psychiatrist and Jungian analyst
根本不在身边，所以她甚至连家具都没有，她只是独自待在一个房间里，看起来很不开心。当时我正在接受一位女性的分析。我可以提她的名字，她叫伊丽莎白·奥斯特曼（Elizabeth Osterman），她曾经见过荣格。她是一位美国精神科医生和荣格分析师，
in the Jung Institute of San Francisco. And she was a very, very careful, serious therapist. She had originally been a virologist and then after getting a PhD in that, went on to go to medical school, become a doctor and eventually became a psychiatrist and Jungian analyst because she was so impressed by her own Jungian analysis. she said the one interpretation she really made is that the woman alone in the room was I said is that Chinese laundress Piggy Wu she doesn't have
在旧金山荣格学院工作。她是一位非常非常细心、严肃的治疗师。她最初是一名病毒学家，在获得博士学位后，继续去医学院学习，成为了一名医生，最终成为了一名精神科医生和荣格分析师，因为她对自己所接受的荣格分析印象非常深刻。她说她真正做出的一个解释是，那个独自在房间里的女人，我说那是中国洗衣女工吴佩吉，她现在什么都没有。
anything now that comment really meant something to me and then I thought about the man that left her alone and didn't give her furniture. I realized that I was seriously neglecting something in myself, that that man had to be my extroverted intuitive ego and although i was not literally gambling i was constantly pursuing possibilities in the world i
那个评论对我来说真的很有意义，然后我想到那个抛下她独自一人、没给她买家具的男人。我意识到我严重忽视了自己内心的一些东西，那个男人一定是我外倾直觉型的自我，虽然我并没有真的在赌博，但我一直在追求世界上的各种可能性。我
mean you'd have to be an extroverted intuitive if you give an extroverted intuitive a city it's sort of dangerous because i happen to love cities and I wouldn't probably want to live in anything but a city. But San Francisco is a wonderful city and it has many bookstores and so forth and movie theaters and so forth. And I'm talking now about San Francisco of around 1972 when I would have had that dream. And in those days, when I finished my day's work, if I read in the newspaper about a book that had been published, I'd drive across the city to the bookstore to get there before it closed so I could buy the book that day or if I heard about a new movie that had opened I would hurry and go to the new movie and I'm a big movie buff so basically pursuing things that might be interesting was
意思是，如果你给一个外倾直觉型的人一座城市，这有点危险，因为我恰好热爱城市，除了城市，我可能不想住在任何地方。但旧金山是一座很棒的城市，它有很多书店、电影院等等。我现在说的是1972年左右的旧金山，那时我应该做了那个梦。在那些日子里，当我完成一天的工作后，如果我在报纸上读到一本刚出版的书，我会开车穿过整个城市去书店，赶在关门前买到那本书；或者如果我听说有一部新电影上映，我会匆忙赶去看。我是一个超级影迷，所以基本上，追求那些可能有趣的事情
taking me away from a more introverted use of time that I wasn't working. And not surprisingly, I was developing various somatic symptoms like migraine headaches and so forth, because I was really pushing the envelope of trying to pursue possibilities,
让我远离了更内倾的时间利用方式，而我当时并没有在工作。不出所料，我开始出现各种躯体症状，比如偏头痛等等，因为我真的在竭尽全力去追求各种可能性，
but not knowing very much about, well, you could say, folding them up and packaging them up and containing the day, something I now spend a lot of time doing at the end of every day. I always liked that you used the concept of the psychisoma in your talks.
但对如何，嗯，你可以说，折叠它们、打包它们并掌控这一天知之甚少，我现在每天结束时都会花很多时间做这些事。我一直很喜欢你在讲座中使用的“身心”（psychisoma）这个概念。
You don't see a lot of somatic psychology in the Jungian world. And I always liked that you connected. Hillman did that too in Emotion, his first book, but you always connected these complexes to physical manifestations. And I think a lot of times that gets left out. Well, you're absolutely right. And you could talk about that theoretically, or I could talk about that theoretically or i could tell you that as i meditated on that dream
在荣格学派中，你很少见到躯体心理学。我一直很喜欢你将两者联系起来。希尔曼（Hillman）在他的第一本书《情绪》（Emotion）中也这样做过，但你总是将这些情结与身体表现联系起来。我认为很多时候这一点被忽略了。嗯，你说得完全对。你可以从理论上谈论这一点，或者我可以从理论上谈论这一点，或者我可以告诉你，当我冥想那个梦时，
i thought okay this woman is holding the clothes and putting them in order. She doesn't wear makeup. She's rather simple in her presentation. She's extremely efficient. I said, you know, this looks like introverted sensation to me. So I had been reading young and I've been reading all the time in those days. And I said that to my analyst. She said, I couldn't agree more. She said, I think that's my inferior function. That's what she was agreeing about. Then I thought, I'm not giving introvert sensation enough. What is introverted sensation?
我想，好吧，这个女人在整理衣服，把它们归位。她不化妆。她的外表相当朴素。她极其高效。我说，你知道，这看起来像是内倾感觉。所以我一直在读荣格的书，那段日子我一直在读。我对我分析师说了这些。她说，我完全同意。她说，我认为那是我的劣势功能。这就是她所同意的。然后我想，我没有给内倾感觉足够的重视。什么是内倾感觉？
Well, I did know it was interested in the efficiency, and I did know that it was very good with detail, like accountants or people who keep track of very, and the folding of the laundry, the way it was put in the whole presentation of Peggy Wu, I'm sure I got her type right. And how, what a hard time I had keeping track of money and accounts. And I mean, there was a, even learning to drive a car was such an achievement for me. I didn't learn until I was 29 years old to drive a car. And I have always had a trouble with sense of direction that could be a problem with extroverted
嗯，我知道它对效率感兴趣，而且我知道它非常擅长细节，比如会计或那些善于记录的人。关于洗衣服的折叠方式，以及吴佩吉呈现出的整体状态，我相信我判断对了她的类型。而我自己在记录金钱和账目方面有多么困难。我的意思是，甚至学开车对我来说都是一项巨大的成就。我直到29岁才学会开车。而且我一直有方向感的问题，这可能也是外倾
sensation as well but particularly keeping order was really a problem for me she had the she had that down but when i thought of her as introverted sensation i thought well let's think about that that sensation i have a good thinking function, so I was using my thinking function. Sensation on the inside of the body. So I reasoned to myself on the inside of the body. Well, let's start with breathing, because that surely is an autonomic nervous system function.
感觉的问题，但保持秩序对我来说确实是个问题。她在这方面做得很好，但当我把她视为内倾感觉时，我想，好吧，让我们思考一下那种感觉。我有一个很好的思维功能，所以我一直在使用我的思维功能。感觉是在身体内部的。所以我对自己进行推理。好吧，让我们从呼吸开始，因为那肯定是一种自主神经系统的功能。
And I knew that I had migraine headaches, which suggested a disturbance of the autonomic nervous system. In fact, what I felt in my migraines were part of a general sympathetic nervous system collapse that I would get into where finally my sympathetic nervous system was pulsing and the very arteries were both expanding and contracting because the pressure I was putting on the inside of my body by this constant running around and stuffing in new books
我知道我有偏头痛，这表明自主神经系统出现了紊乱。事实上，我在偏头痛中感受到的，是我陷入的一种普遍的交感神经系统崩溃的一部分，最终我的交感神经系统在跳动，动脉在扩张和收缩，因为我通过不断地奔波和塞入新书，
and new ideas and new movies and new books, it was just too much. And it was like, it was like addiction, but not thank heaven drug addiction, but it was a form of, it was an extroverted, intuitive inflation around the emergent world. And a lot was emerging in the early 70s. It was a very exciting time. So it was a lot, including the fact
新想法、新电影和新书，给我的身体内部施加了太大的压力，这简直太多了。这就像，这就像成瘾，谢天谢地不是毒瘾，但它是一种围绕着新兴世界的、外倾直觉型的膨胀。70年代初有很多新兴事物。那是一个非常令人兴奋的时代。所以有很多东西，包括这样一个事实：
that was in Jungian analysis, after all, and becoming a Jungian analyst. I picked up on that emerging trend ahead of most people of my generation. And so that was a big deal. But something in me was really out of kilter. And so I began to attend to my breath in the therapeutic hours. And what I noticed was I was doing a lot of Jungian reading,
毕竟我当时正在接受荣格分析，并且正在成为一名荣格分析师。我比我那一代的大多数人更早地捕捉到了这种新兴趋势。所以这是一件大事。但我内心有什么东西真的失调了。所以我开始在治疗时间里关注我的呼吸。我注意到我正在做大量的荣格阅读，
and I was particularly reading the works of von Franz, and he's a phenomenal associate of Jung's, V-O-N-F-R-A-N-Z, for those who don't know her work. And her collected works are now coming out of Chiron Publications, so they're readily available. In those days, they were coming out as a series of books from spring publications. The Interpretation of Fairy Tales, Shadow and Evil in Fairy Tales, The Problem of the Feminine in Fairy Tales,
我特别在读冯·弗兰兹（von Franz）的作品，她是荣格的一位杰出的同事，对于那些不了解她作品的人，她的名字是V-O-N-F-R-A-N-Z。她的文集现在正由凯龙出版社（Chiron Publications）出版，所以很容易买到。在那些日子里，它们作为一系列书籍由春季出版社（Spring Publications）出版。《童话中的解读》、《童话中的阴影与邪恶》、《童话中女性的问题》，
a marvelous book on the golden ass of apollos a roman novel a marvelous book in which he analyzes that the problem of the poor eternists that everybody every young in was reading at that time the eternal boy problem and certainly any of the roman stock types of that era, you feel like those are describing MBTI functions, you know? Or any, you know, it seems like you kind of get people who use a different, maybe a more intuitive language to talk about the same MBTI functions. Like Robert Moore towards the end of his life
一本关于阿普列尤斯的《金驴记》的精彩著作，一部罗马小说，一本精彩的书，她在书中分析了当时每个荣格学派都在读的“永恒少年”问题，以及那个时代任何罗马式的典型人物，你觉得这些是在描述MBTI功能，你知道吗？或者任何，你知道，似乎你得到的人使用了一种不同的、也许更直观的语言来谈论相同的MBTI功能。比如罗伯特·摩尔（Robert Moore）在他生命末期
is doing the four, you know, aspects of the mature masculine or something. Do you see any overlap between the MBTI and other things that people may already be using or familiar with? Well, where I came in was to see that, von Frantz seemed to think that the inferior function was the place, the doorway through which all these different archetypes come. So for me, that inferior function was introverted sensation. So I began to want to sort the archetypes. And that's what I began to do with my type work. So I found it as a very good way to understand where archetypes is where types of consciousness emerge but i wouldn't have gotten there without the work i did on on the interior of my body with
正在做关于成熟男性的四个方面之类的研究。你是否看到MBTI和其他人们可能已经在使用的或熟悉的事物之间有任何重叠？嗯，我的切入点是看到冯·弗兰兹似乎认为劣势功能是所有这些不同原型进入的门户。所以对我来说，那个劣势功能就是内倾感觉。所以我开始想要整理这些原型。这就是我开始用我的类型工作所做的事情。所以我发现这是一种理解意识类型从何处涌现的非常好的方法，但如果不是因为我在身体内部所做的工作，
breathing so i'll stay with it for just a little longer so you can see that you sort of i realize i'm taking you through a very particular point, but imagine that I'm taking the thread through the eye of the needle right now. Okay. Put up with this tediousness a little bit. I had to too. I had to sit with my body and I had to realize what I was doing. Now, I was reading Von Franz and I adore dream. And I love to work with dreams. And I trained myself to hear what dreams are saying. And each patient that came in, and of course, people knowing you're
通过呼吸，我可能无法达到这一点。所以我再多停留一会儿，这样你就能明白，我意识到我正在带你经历一个非常具体的点，但想象一下我此刻正把线穿过针眼。好吧。稍微忍受一下这种枯燥。我也必须这样做。我必须静下心来感受我的身体，我必须意识到我在做什么。现在，我正在读冯·弗兰兹的书，我崇拜梦。我喜欢处理梦。我训练自己去听梦在说什么。每一个进来的病人，当然，人们知道你
interested in dreams, will certainly give you dreams. That doesn't mean that you're shaping the dreams, but it became a real part of the work i did with so many people and i think to their benefit they i wasn't just laying a union trip on them they really wanted to tell me their dreams people do like to work with dreams and it does and they really help young is right about that and union analysts can get rather good at it if you do anything you do you can get rather good at it. If you do anything you do, you can get rather good at it. If you play baseball, you get good at it. If you do dream analysis all the time, you get good at it.
对梦感兴趣，肯定会给你讲梦。这并不意味着你在塑造这些梦，但它确实成为了我与许多人工作的一个真正部分，我认为这对他们有益。我并不是在向他们灌输荣格那一套，他们真的想告诉我他们的梦。人们确实喜欢处理梦，而且它确实很有帮助，荣格关于这一点是对的，荣格分析师可以变得相当擅长。如果你做任何事，你都可以变得相当擅长。如果你打棒球，你就会变得擅长。如果你一直做梦分析，你就会变得擅长。
I mean, and I myself was writing down 30 dreams a week at that time. I was really, you know, very interested in dreams. So, but what was happening to my body when I was working with the dreams is that I was so interested in the images and the archetypes and what all the people in those days were saying. And I and others came out of that wake of all that interest that was already being laid down. I mean, Jungian analysis was just the emergent thing in the early 70s. So there were plenty. And I would write the dreams down that the patient told them. But I would also, as I would listen to dreams, and this was me noticing, taking my own dream about the Chinese laundress not having anything, and my own Jungian analyst woman saying she doesn't have anything, and me saying that's introverted sensation. I've
我的意思是，我自己当时每周写下30个梦。我真的，你知道，对梦非常感兴趣。所以，当我在处理梦时，我的身体发生了什么，是我对这些意象、原型以及当时所有人所说的话太感兴趣了。我和其他人都是在所有这些已经奠定的兴趣浪潮中走出来的。我的意思是，荣格分析在70年代初就是新兴事物。所以有很多。我会写下病人告诉他们的梦。但我也在听梦的时候，这是我注意到的，我拿我自己的关于中国洗衣女工一无所有的梦，以及我自己的荣格分析师说她什么都没有，而我说那是内倾感觉。我
got to give more attention to it. So I'm paying attention to my breathing now as I'm listening to the patient. And I notice that I'm so excited about the emergent archetypal images and what they mean. And my extrovert intuition is so wrapped with attention that I'm literally listening with bated breath. And that for significant minutes of each day, as I'm in my office working with patients, I'm not even breathing, lest it disturb the thinking about the archetype and the interpretation
必须给予它更多关注。所以现在我在听病人说话时关注我的呼吸。我注意到我对那些新兴的原型意象以及它们的含义感到非常兴奋。我的外倾直觉被注意力紧紧包裹，以至于我简直是屏住呼吸在听。在每天的每一段重要时间里，当我在办公室与病人工作时，我甚至连呼吸都没有，生怕它干扰了对原型和解释的思考，
I could possibly deliver. So no wonder I had this terrible carbon dioxide poisoning in my body. No wonder I wasn't breathing normally. So I thought, you know, I've got to take care of her. I've got to take care of the introverted sensation anima carrying the inferior function of introverted sensation. This lonely Chinese woman. I had learned the Anima was the archetype of otherness. And so she was certainly other. She was from another part of the world.
我可能传达出来的。所以难怪我的身体里有这种可怕的二氧化碳中毒。难怪我没有正常呼吸。所以我心想，你知道，我必须照顾她。我必须照顾那个承载着内倾感觉劣势功能的内倾感觉阿尼玛。这个孤独的中国女人。我学到阿尼玛是“他者”的原型。所以她当然是“他者”。她来自世界的另一个地方。
And she was obviously different from me in every possible way, female and the opposite type, introverted sensation, or at least the inverse type to extroverted intuition so in a case i'm paying attention to my breathing i notice i'm with beta breasts i thought i am going to have to breathe while i listen and talk i can't just listen with baited breath and then deliver an interpretation i've got to get to. So I started making room for my breathing. And patients noticed.
而且她在各方面显然都与我不同，女性，相反的类型，内倾感觉，或者至少是外倾直觉的逆类型。所以，在某种情况下，我关注我的呼吸，我注意到我屏住呼吸，我想我必须在倾听和交谈时呼吸。我不能只是屏住呼吸然后给出一个解释，我必须做到这一点。所以我开始为我的呼吸腾出空间。病人们注意到了。
They could hear me sighing and exhaling and inhaling. And people would comment on it. But what I found is that in that way, and this is something every therapist will find, that by carefully listening to what was going on in my body in the introverted, sensate way, I would be able to locate affects that were quite relevant to what the patient was saying
他们能听到我的叹息、呼气和吸气。人们会对此发表评论。但我发现，通过这种方式，这是每个治疗师都会发现的，通过仔细倾听我身体里以那种内倾感觉方式发生的事情，我能够定位到与病人所说的话非常相关的情感，
that were precisely not what was being symbolized in the dreams. Precisely not what we were talking about at the thinking intuitive level, but what was going on at the body. And I could suddenly say things to people like, I can't say why, but I'm just getting the feeling of incredible sadness right now. And the patient would just burst into tears.
这些情感恰恰不是梦中所象征的东西。恰恰不是我们在思维直觉层面所谈论的东西，而是身体层面正在发生的事情。我突然可以对人们说一些话，比如，我说不出为什么，但我现在就是有一种难以置信的悲伤感。然后病人就会突然泪流满面。
And so what I found is every therapist will find that it's not what I could do brilliantly off the top of my absolutely inferior sensation. But if I'm listening to my body, I could get much closer to that, which was just as emergent and just as at the heart of the dream, but not being talked about by the client. So I became a much better therapist, much better therapist. And it was all because I had a dream, told me my introverted sensation didn't have anything. And then I, and so then I could really relate to the dirty laundry and get it cleaned and do my job. And so you can only imagine so when i discovered that i thought well if paying attention to an anima figure carrying a function of consciousness that's inferior what if all the figures that i see in the dreams my dreams and other people's dreams
所以我发现每个治疗师都会发现，这不是我能从我那绝对劣势的感觉中出色地做到的。但如果我倾听我的身体，我就能更接近那个同样是新兴的、同样处于梦的核心，但客户没有谈论的东西。所以我成了一名更好的治疗师，好得多的治疗师。这一切都是因为我做了一个梦，告诉我我的内倾感觉什么都没有。然后我，所以我可以真正与脏衣服建立联系，把它洗干净，做好我的工作。所以你可以想象，当我发现这一点时，我想，如果关注一个承载着劣势意识功能的阿尼玛形象，那么如果我在梦中、我的梦中和其他人的梦中看到的所有形象，
each of them is holding in archetypal form, a consciousness that needs to be unpacked. And if we did that for everyone, where is it? What is it containing? And from that, I started to really passionately live the eight function model that you see me writing about now. That's where that came from and you so you're absolutely right right through the body well and you said the dream changed then you know you revisited the Peggy Sue and saw that her husband was treating her better after after I started breathing I made room for her she said uh she looked happier and uh it was and And her husband was taking her out now for ice cream. And she looked happier.
每一个都以原型的形式持有一种需要被解构的意识。如果我们对每个人都这样做，它在哪里？它包含什么？从那时起，我开始真正充满激情地实践你现在看到我写的八功能模型。这就是它的来源。所以你是完全正确的，通过身体。嗯，你说梦变了，然后你知道，你重温了佩吉·吴，看到她的丈夫在开始呼吸后对她更好了。我为她腾出了空间，她说，呃，她看起来更快乐了，呃，这是，而且她的丈夫现在带她出去吃冰淇淋了。她看起来更快乐了。
But as someone said who I told that dream to, a woman in one of my seminars, she said, well, it's going to take a lot more than ice cream to take care of her. And of course, that's true. And it was so that basically, the way I've taken care of Peggy Wu is very, very interesting. I mean, you know, she was from a very wealthy family in China. But then the Japanese invaded. Her grandfather was the richest man in her town. and he was hung by the Japanese and his body publicly displayed. So the family lost everything
但正如我告诉过那个梦的一个人，我研讨会上的一个女人所说的那样，她说，嗯，照顾她需要的不仅仅是冰淇淋。当然，这是真的。所以基本上，我照顾吴佩吉的方式非常非常有趣。我的意思是，你知道，她来自中国一个非常富裕的家庭。但后来日本人入侵了。她的祖父是她镇上最富有的人，他被日本人吊死，尸体被公开展示。所以这个家庭失去了一切，
as she came here. But it became a powerful symbol for you that you resonated with? I had lived in China as a child for two years when i 15 1946 and 48 and i went to an american school that was called the hillcrest american school that that had um children from um it's run by missionaries created by missionaries and it was for it was the by missionaries, created by missionaries. And it was, the classes were in English. The people who were there were people who were sons and daughters of ambassadors to China,
当她来到这里时。但这成为了一个与你产生共鸣的强大象征？我小时候在中国住过两年，15岁时，1946年到48年，我上了一所美国学校，叫希尔克雷斯特美国学校（Hillcrest American School），那里有来自……它是由传教士经营的，由传教士创建的，它是为……由传教士创建的。而且，课程是用英语授课的。在那里的人是驻华大使的儿女，
first secretaries to China from the diplomatic corps. My father was a military attache or an assistant military attache, and we lived in a big house in Nanking, as we called it nowadays. It would be called Nanjing, but we called it in those days Nanking. I remember walking home from school one day and passing a Chinese girl. She looked at me, this was about 1948 when I was perhaps nine years old, maybe still eight years old. I turned nine that year.
驻华外交使团的一等秘书。我父亲是武官或助理武官，我们住在南京的一栋大房子里，我们现在称之为南京，但在那个年代我们称之为南京（Nanking）。我记得有一天放学回家，经过一个中国女孩。她看着我，那大约是1948年，我大约九岁，也许还是八岁。那年我九岁了。
She looked at me in very slow, careful English. She was about 12 years old. She looked at me and said, you are a pig. Well, little did I know that in 1998, I would get the opportunity to be sent by the International Association of Analytical Psychology on a diplomatic mission, not unlike my father's after World War II,
她看着我，用非常缓慢、仔细的英语说，你是一头猪。好吧，我没想到在1998年，我会有机会被国际分析心理学协会派去执行外交任务，这和我父亲二战后的任务没什么两样，
to go and speak at the first International Congress of Analytical Psychology and Chinese Culture, which was organized by a man who had studied in America named Dr. Ho-Yung Shin, S-H-E-N, studied personality psychology in Illinois and gotten to know Murray Stein and had previously invited Murray Stein to come to China with Thomas Kirsch, who was at that time the president of the International Association. Now, when I'm sent, Murray Stein is the president of the organization, and Hoi Anxin is having this conference, and Murray Stein wants me to go because he knows that I'm interested in China, because I lived in China and I happened to have spent a lot of time studying the Chinese book, the I Ching. And Dr. Shen and I met in San Francisco.
去参加第一届国际分析心理学与中国文化大会，该大会由一位在美国学习过的名叫沈和勇（Ho-Yung Shin）博士组织，他在伊利诺伊州学习人格心理学，并结识了默里·斯坦（Murray Stein），此前曾邀请默里·斯坦与当时担任国际协会主席的托马斯·克什（Thomas Kirsch）一起去中国。现在，当我被派去时，默里·斯坦是该组织的主席，沈和勇正在举办这次会议，默里·斯坦希望我去，因为他知道我对中国感兴趣，因为我在中国住过，而且我恰好花了很多时间研究中国的《易经》。沈博士和我在旧金山见过面。
Dr. Kirshen was in San Francisco and introduced me. He and I would talk about the I Ching when he was in America. So I was invited. And so I went and I gave the I Ching when he was in America. And then he, so I was invited. And so I went and I gave the keynote address there, the opening address, and also the closing address. That began work that I continue now with. I've been going to China and during the pandemic. Now I just am online. At least 10 hours of my work week is always spent with people in China. And now China has not only Jungian analysts, but it has its own
克什博士当时在旧金山，并介绍了我。当他在美国时，我们经常谈论《易经》。所以我被邀请了。所以我去了，我在那里发表了主旨演讲，开幕词，还有闭幕词。那开启了我现在仍在继续的工作。我一直在去中国，在疫情期间。现在我只是在线上。我每周至少有10个小时的工作时间是和中国的人在一起。现在中国不仅有荣格分析师，而且有自己的
analytical society of Jungian analysts. And they, this last year in August, were finally granted the right to do their own training. So little did I know that I would one day have a chance to do something for China, and that I could do something about being a pig. And so I was, and here I was in here I was here right here here I had this chance had I and I have been teaching typology in China and it has caught on there as perhaps even nowhere else in the sense that they all learn it and when I talk to people in China or I mean I can have a person in my practice and I can say, well, that particular image in your dream seems like an image of the trickster. Oh, yes, function number seven, he says. They know my model perfectly and they use it all the time in their work on dreams and everything else.
荣格分析师分析协会。去年八月，他们终于获得了进行自己培训的权利。所以我没想到有一天我会有机会为中国做点什么，而且我可以做点什么来弥补“猪”这件事。所以我是，我在这里，我在这里，我有这个机会，我一直在中国教授类型学，它在那里流行起来，也许在其他任何地方都没有，因为他们都学习它。当我与中国的人交谈时，或者我的意思是，我的诊所里可以有一个人，我可以说，嗯，你梦中的那个特定意象看起来像是捣蛋鬼（Trickster）的意象。哦，是的，功能七，他说。他们完美地了解我的模型，并在他们对梦和其他一切的工作中一直使用它。
Now, who would have ever thought that? So that that embedded in that dream and in the body problem that I had to solve in that dream was not just introverted sensation, but it turned out to open an avenue to extroverted sensation. All these trips to China, all this work and even my willingness to learn, as many intuitive men of my generation had to learn to use the internet and use it well enough so that i could do teaching both at a distance and able to go there and so um who would ever have believed that all this could come out of the Chinese laundress that didn't have anything that I took seriously
现在，谁会想到呢？所以，嵌入在那个梦中以及我必须在那个梦中解决的身体问题中的，不仅仅是内倾感觉，它最终打开了一条通往外倾感觉的途径。所有这些去中国的旅行，所有这些工作，甚至我学习的意愿，正如我那一代的许多直觉型男性必须学习使用互联网并很好地使用它，以便我既能远程教学，又能去那里。所以，嗯，谁会相信这一切都来自那个我认真对待的、一无所有的中国洗衣女工，
and gave her something. I mean, who knew that it would be like that? But it is like that. And this past year, I was able to do a special issue of this Journal of Analytical Psychology on psychological types. And there's a marvelous article about the correlation between the eight trigrams that are so famous in Asian cultures, that four of them are on the flag of Korea. They're called the eight Gua,
并给了她一些东西。我的意思是，谁知道会是这样？但事实就是这样。去年，我能够为《分析心理学杂志》做一期关于心理类型的特刊。有一篇关于亚洲文化中非常著名的八卦之间相关性的精彩文章，其中四个在韩国国旗上。它们被称为八卦，
which are the essential units of the I Ching, which is a book of wisdom. And this he has made what for me is the most convincing correlation between the eight Gua and the eight function attitudes of consciousness. His name is Professor Tsai and his Chinese name is Ching Ho. So if we said his name in the English way, it would be Ching Ho Tsai, but because in China the last family name is always first, I know him as Tsai Ching Ho. Tsai Ching Ho published this in the special issue. And so
它们是《易经》的基本单位，这是一本智慧之书。他做出了我认为关于八卦和八种意识功能态度之间最令人信服的相关性。他的名字是蔡教授，他的中文名字是清和。所以如果我们用英语说他的名字，那将是清和蔡（Ching Ho Tsai），但因为在中国姓氏总是放在前面，所以我称他为蔡清和。蔡清和在特刊上发表了这篇文章。所以
at last the link between China and typology that began with that dream has actually turned into something that I think could really be helpful, because I see now that the ancient Gua really were the first discovery of the eight billion particles that Jung found entirely differently. Jung often found that his work that came out of a completely Western source had an Asian and particularly a Chinese analog. And through his friendship with Richard Wilhelm, who is the translator, spent 25 years in China of the famous I Ching but now think of my life
终于，从那个梦开始的中国与类型学之间的联系，实际上已经变成了一种我认为可能非常有帮助的东西，因为我现在看到古代的八卦确实是荣格以完全不同的方式发现的八种粒子（功能）的首次发现。荣格经常发现他的工作源于完全西方的来源，却有一个亚洲，特别是中国的模拟。通过他与理查德·威廉（Richard Wilhelm）的友谊，他是翻译者，在中国花了25年翻译著名的《易经》，但现在想想我的生活，
there's a doctoral student in London who's been doing the definitive work on Wilhelm's entire contribution and how it fits into analytical psychology and studying Jung history.
伦敦有一位博士生一直在做关于威廉全部贡献的决定性工作，以及它如何融入分析心理学和研究荣格历史。
And Sonu Shandasani, who translated the Red Book, and he's a graduate student there. And he and I can talk. I've been to Wilhelm's school in China twice. He and I have talked about what Wilhelm did, and he's been able to go into the Wilhelm archive in Leipzig, and I've been able to talk to him about that. He is the person who translated my types book into Chinese for the Chinese to have.
翻译了《红书》的索努·沙姆达萨尼（Sonu Shandasani），他是那里的研究生。我和他可以交谈。我去过威廉在中国创办的学校两次。我和他谈过威廉所做的事情，他能够进入莱比锡的威廉档案馆，我也能够和他谈论那个。他就是把我的类型书翻译成中文供中国人阅读的人。
So we have that kind of connection. All of that phenomenal textured richness of actual thinking feeling sensation all coming out as well as my intuition out of taking that chinese wander stream seriously i just think it's amazing how much can come from just that if that isn't consciousness emerging what is i mean that's what i'm talking about that's what i'm hoping to hand like that interpretation she doesn't have anything that's what i'm really trying to do for other people if they read my stuff they'll say wait a minute maybe that could do something with me and who knows what's in that surprise package for those people. But they've also got to make it real by taking it into their own body and also their own spirit and their own soul in their own way.
所以我们有那种联系。所有那些实际思维、情感、感觉的现象级纹理丰富性，以及我的直觉，都源于认真对待那个中国洗衣女工的梦。我只是觉得从那一点点东西中能产生这么多东西真是太神奇了。如果那不是意识的涌现，那是什么？我的意思是，这就是我在谈论的，这就是我希望传递的，像那个解释“她什么都没有”，这就是我真正试图为其他人做的，如果他们读我的东西，他们会说，等一下，也许那能对我做点什么。谁知道那些惊喜包裹里有什么呢？但他们也必须通过以自己的方式将其带入自己的身体、自己的精神和自己的灵魂来使其成为现实。
That's obviously true. So that's why I took you through the eye of the needle, because I wanted you to see the crate. It really like that wonderful, it's mistranslated, but a camel going through the eye of the needle is a wonderful image in the New Testament. It's actually a camel hair, but it turns out to be the slenderest thread
这显然是真的。所以这就是为什么我带你穿过针眼，因为我想让你看到那个箱子。它真的很像那个美妙的，虽然翻译错了，但骆驼穿过针眼是新约中一个美妙的意象。它实际上是骆驼毛，但结果证明是最细的线，
turns out to be the very rope of life. It's just really interesting. It's really interesting. Well, yeah, I think there's kind of a push like in the 80s. It seems like there's a lot of, I don't know if you would call them post-Jungian or what, like models where people leave the institute, they're kind of feel constrained by just pure analysis.
结果证明是生命的绳索。这真的很有趣。这真的很有趣。嗯，是的，我认为80年代有一种推动力。似乎有很多，我不知道你是否称他们为后荣格学派或其他什么，比如人们离开学院的模型，他们觉得受到纯分析的限制。
We're familiar with likenold mendel that does the process therapy or sidren house stone i mean they both leave and kind of turn a yugi therapy very excited mind and so forth yeah yeah dream body or something like that his thesis is that the symbol and the dream is the is also corresponds to a place in the body at that level of i mean i would call it the subcortical brain you know is this place in the body that that level of, I mean, I would call it the subcortical brain, you know, is this place where the kind of deep unconscious mind is not cognitive. It's not thinking, you know, it's conscious, but it's not thinking in language.
我们熟悉做过程疗法的莱肯诺德·门德尔（Likenold Mendel）或西德伦·豪斯通（Sidren House Stone），我的意思是他们都离开了，并以某种方式转向了尤吉疗法，非常兴奋的头脑等等。是的，是的，梦体之类的。他的论点是，梦中的符号也对应于身体中那个层面的位置。我的意思是，我会称之为皮层下大脑，你知道，这是身体中那个深层潜意识思维不是认知性的地方。它不是思考，你知道，它是意识，但它不是用语言思考。
And that's sort of enmeshed with muscle responses and physicality, you know, at that level of thinking. But you just see a lot of that. And I wonder if it's people wanting to break into the body when they're leaving the institutes in that period and starting these new somatic Jungian models. Well, it's present in Jung, but it gets lost. I don't...
这与肌肉反应和身体性交织在一起，你知道，在那种思维层面上。但你确实看到了很多这种情况。我想知道这是否是人们在那个时期离开学院并开始这些新的躯体荣格模型时，想要闯入身体的愿望。嗯，它存在于荣格中，但它丢失了。我不……
I'll say it this way. One of the shadow problems of Christianity, which became the dominant religion of the West, is its attitude toward the body and it's strange because it depends on how you read Christianity I mean you know St. Thomas Aquinas didn't leave the body out I mean if he talks about how, what does it mean that there's a resurrection? And there's a long, wonderful passages. go up to heaven? Yes, the fingernails go up to heaven. Eyelashes go. He's very clear. It's very almost hilarious
我这样说吧。基督教的阴影问题之一，它成为了西方的主导宗教，是对身体的态度。这很奇怪，因为它取决于你如何阅读基督教。我的意思是，你知道，圣托马斯·阿奎那并没有把身体排除在外。我的意思是，如果他谈论复活意味着什么？有很长、很精彩的段落。去天堂吗？是的，指甲去天堂。睫毛去。他非常清楚。这几乎是滑稽的，
that all the people ask, trying to say, well, surely it's just the spirit that goes up. No, no, no. It's absolutely the body. And of course, the central Christian mystery is the literal resurrection of Jesus. Now, I'm not going to get into whether that's one's belief or not, but what people's, where the bread is the flesh of Christ and the wine is the blood of Christ, taking that into one system in an embodied way. So when I say that there's a bias against the body,
所有人都问，试图说，嗯，肯定只有精神上天堂。不，不，不。绝对是身体。当然，基督教的核心奥秘是耶稣的字面复活。现在，我不会讨论这是否是一个人的信仰，但人们的，面包是基督的肉，酒是基督的血，以一种具体化的方式将其带入一个人的系统。所以当我说对身体有偏见时，
I want to also point out there's also a bias against the part of Christianity that is embodied. So I want to be very clear that I'm not just making a cheap shot, an uninformed shot. At its best, Christianity is, we're told repeatedly who are interested in Christianity and are Christians. They're told repeatedly that if you don't abide in it isn't christianity so that so let's be sure that i i say that but nevertheless there was a certain medieval attitude toward the spirit and even and thomas aquinas had to fight it
我也想指出，对基督教中具体化的那一部分也有偏见。所以我想要非常清楚，我不仅仅是在进行廉价的、无知的攻击。在最好的情况下，基督教是，我们被反复告知那些对基督教感兴趣并是基督徒的人。他们被反复告知，如果你不遵守，那就不是基督教。所以，让我们确保我说了这一点，但尽管如此，确实存在一种中世纪的对精神的态度，甚至托马斯·阿奎那也必须与之斗争，
then and that and it it's it's a tendency to spiritualize things and ignore the body and certainly that was what was happening to me with it i was certainly was picked up on the spirit of union psychology but i also had to get into the body and in young's mysterium conjunctionis which is a long hard and sometimes boring book to read, but has a brilliant finale. He talks about an alchemist named Dorn, Diorian, and he talks about something that Edward Endger picks up on, which is the conjunction in Latin, coniunctio, the conjunction of psychic opposites,
然后，这是一种将事物精神化并忽视身体的倾向，当然，这正是我所经历的。我当然捕捉到了荣格心理学的精神，但我也必须进入身体。在荣格的《神秘结合》（Mysterium Conjunctionis）中，这是一本漫长、艰难、有时读起来很无聊的书，但有一个精彩的结局。他谈到了一位名叫多恩（Dorn）的炼金术士，他谈到了一些爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）所关注的东西，即拉丁语中的结合（coniunctio），心理对立面的结合，
the coming together of opposites. That's huge with Jung, of course, and the idea of a conjunction. But Dorn talks about a lesser coniunctio. He's a Rosicrucian of approximately the 16th century, a lesser coniunctio and a greater coniuntio. And the lesser coniuntio is what he calls the unio mentalis, the mental union,
对立面的汇合。这在荣格那里当然是巨大的，以及结合的概念。但多恩谈到了较小的结合和较大的结合。他是一位大约16世纪的玫瑰十字会成员，较小的结合和较大的结合。较小的结合就是他所说的“精神结合”（unio mentalis），即精神与灵魂的结合，
the union of spirit and soul. Now, the term spirit and soul, some people think they should be identical. They're not. James Holman did a beautiful essay on the difference between spirit and soul. The essay is called Peaks and Veils. It's one of my favorite of his essays. I heard him give it in person, and it's amazing. I felt like I was listening to one of the great jazz performances of all time, but it was jazz of introverted thinking by this great introverted thinking general way Hellman had. So the union of spirit and soul is the union mentalis.
精神与灵魂的结合。现在，术语“精神”和“灵魂”，有些人认为它们应该是相同的。它们不是。詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）写了一篇关于精神与灵魂之间区别的美丽文章。这篇文章叫《高峰与面纱》（Peaks and Veils）。这是我最喜欢的他的文章之一。我亲耳听他讲过，这太神奇了。我觉得我正在听有史以来最伟大的爵士乐表演之一，但那是希尔曼那种伟大的内倾思维方式的内倾思维爵士乐。所以精神与灵魂的结合就是精神结合。
And that is sort of unfortunately where I was before I had the Chinese laundromat stream, because I was taking soul experiences, feelings, affects, depressions, sadnesses, that kind of thing, and bringing a basically spiritual interpretation of the archetypes, the dreams. And so I had a lot of intellectual insight. I was bringing my mind together. I had a union mentalis, a mental union. So I had a lot of gifts as a young psychiatrist at being able to match up a feeling state with its meaning, which made me quite precocious and very, I mean, it made me
而在我做那个中国洗衣店梦之前，不幸的是，我正处于那种状态，因为我正在获取灵魂体验、感受、情感、抑郁、悲伤之类的事情，并对原型、梦境进行了一种基本的精神解释。所以我有很多智力上的洞察力。我把我的思想结合在一起。我有了精神结合。所以我作为一名年轻的精神科医生，在将情感状态与其含义相匹配方面有很多天赋，这使我相当早熟，非常，我的意思是，它使我
the chief resident of psychiatry at Stanford. And I was accepted into training readily by the Young Eastern San Francisco. I mean, I had a kind of brilliant union mentalis, but I was leaving the other thing out. And that other thing is the body. So that from Dorne, the greater union teo is when you take that union mentalis, the union of spirit and soul, and return it to the body or bring the body into it. And then you have the divine troika of spirit, soul, and body. So when I work with people now, I try to see who they are and notice that there are many other examples of taking two out of the three and trying to pretend that's wholeness. A lot of people who have the spirit and the body, and their bodies are great, and their
成为斯坦福大学精神病学的首席住院医师。我很容易被旧金山荣格学院录取进行培训。我的意思是，我有一种辉煌的精神结合，但我把另一件事漏掉了。而另一件事就是身体。所以从多恩那里，更大的结合是当你把那个精神结合，即精神与灵魂的结合，归还给身体或将身体带入其中。然后你就有了精神、灵魂和身体的神圣三位一体。所以当我现在与人工作时，我试图看看他们是谁，并注意到还有许多其他例子，将三者中的两者拿出来，试图假装那是完整性。很多人拥有精神和身体，他们的身体很棒，他们的
spirit is great, the soul is left out. Or then there are people who are very body-soul. They've a body and soul, like great torch singers. They have a great soul and a great body, and they have no room for the spirit the spirit is more likely sometimes called the mind to me they're all parts in a way depends on how you use the word mind but i love that idea that it's of course there are people who have none that people only have one but i'm talking about reasonably developed people people like yourself and myself who are already therapists already aware of things practicing and trying to help
精神很棒，灵魂被遗漏了。或者还有一些人是非常身心合一的。他们有身体和灵魂，就像伟大的灵魂歌手。他们有伟大的灵魂和伟大的身体，他们没有精神的空间。精神有时更可能被称为头脑。对我来说，它们在某种程度上都是部分，取决于你如何使用“头脑”这个词，但我喜欢那个想法，当然有些人什么都没有，有些人只有一个，但我谈论的是相当发达的人，像你和我这样的人，已经是治疗师，已经意识到事物，正在实践并试图提供帮助。
people and helping themselves and developing methods it's amazing how often we choose two out of the three and think we don't even need the other and have a subtle contempt for the other whichever the other is. And is that the unlived life of the parent a lot of the time? I mean, my experience is that the part of self that people minimize is usually the psychic territory mom and dad never mastered, or the culture maybe can function as a parent sometimes. You know, you could say that my father was the spirit and my mother was the soul.
人们在帮助自己和发展方法时，令人惊奇的是，我们经常在三者中选择其二，认为自己甚至不需要第三者，并对那个被忽略的（无论它是哪一个）怀有一种微妙的轻蔑。这在很大程度上是父母未竟的生活吗？我的经验是，人们最小化的那部分自我，通常是父母从未掌握的心理领域，或者文化有时可以作为父母发挥作用。你可以说，我父亲是精神，我母亲是灵魂。
And I was left, the body was dumped on me. And I was the one that was processing the unconscious for all of them. And so that you could say that. And I think you wouldn't be far wrong. I think that's a great idea, Joel, that you have. And you're absolutely right. So, but when you think of the wholeness as you have to sort of, wholeness is something you have to triangulate. You stop being in love with four and you start being in love with three. It's at one place where one wag once said that all Jungians divide things into four and all Freudians divide things into
而我被留下了，身体被丢给了我。我是那个为他们所有人处理潜意识的人。所以你可以这么说。我想你说的没错。乔尔，你的这个想法很棒。你是绝对正确的。所以，当你想到完整性时，你必须以某种方式，完整性是你必须进行三角测量（综合）的东西。你不再爱四，而开始爱三。正如一位俏皮话家曾经说过的，所有的荣格派将事物分为四类，而所有的弗洛伊德派将事物分为
three. The part that Jung... Yeah, that's interesting numerology. I never thought of that. Or not has three, Jung has four. The one thing Jung lost when he left Freud was Freud had a very lively sense of the body. And I think that Jung was embodied, but sometimes in his theory, a lot of people are using Jungian psychology as if it has no body or as if it's an easy escape from the body, and that's too bad. Well, and it's strange, too, because it wasn't how he practiced. He was pretty experiential, but a lot of times I think analysis, that's too bad. Well, and it's strange too, because it wasn't how he practiced. He was pretty experiential, but a lot of times I think analysis becomes just purely intellectual and analytical in it.
三类。荣格的那部分……是的，那是有趣的数字命理学。我从未想过这一点。或者说，荣格没有三，荣格有四。荣格离开弗洛伊德时失去的一件事是，弗洛伊德对身体有着非常敏锐的感觉。我认为荣格是有具身性的，但有时在他的理论中，很多人使用荣格心理学时，就好像它没有身体，或者好像它是逃避身体的一种简单方式，这太糟糕了。嗯，这也很奇怪，因为这并不是他的实践方式。他相当注重经验，但我认为很多时候分析，这太糟糕了。嗯，这也很奇怪，因为这并不是他的实践方式。他相当注重经验，但我认为很多时候分析变得纯粹是理智和分析性的了。
Or, or, you know, mentalis soul and spirit, but, but nobody. Have you ever seen anyone that does that? Uh,
或者，或者，你知道，心理、灵魂和精神，但，但没有身体。你见过有人这样做吗？呃，
neuro stem or neurofeedback? It's kind of a newer technology. There's a place here. They have the QEG. There's a friend of mine who did biofeedback for years, so I know a lot about that. But I don't know as much about some of the things that I've been hearing about lately that I do know about that some of my clients have gotten into,
神经干预或神经反馈？这是一种较新的技术。这里有个地方。他们有QEG（定量脑电图）。我有个朋友做了多年的生物反馈，所以我对此了解很多。但我对最近听到的一些事情了解不多，虽然我知道我的一些客户已经开始接触这些了，
which is mapping and EEG. Yeah,eg maps that's it which is the biofeedback is a little bit different um there's a visual um with qeg and so i'm not an mg i mean we're working with a clinic here we've kind of done some experiments where i'll do brain spotting on one of the owners while she has the cap on and then you get to see what it's doing and when her body feels this way and then the body turns into an emotion where the things move which is kind of an interesting um you know learning thing but when you're do you have any idea like where these things are in the brain or what the brain is doing i mean jungians are pretty phenomenological but when they're and the guys are doctors and engineers that have built this thing but you know and again I'm not a doctor. I'm trying to explain, you know, something that's probably above my pay grade.
也就是映射和脑电图。是的，脑电图映射，就是那个。生物反馈有点不同，嗯，QEG有一个视觉效果，所以我不是医生，我的意思是，我们正在与这里的一家诊所合作，我们做了一些实验，我会对其中一位所有者进行脑点定位（Brainspotting），同时她戴着脑电帽，然后你可以看到它在做什么，当她的身体有这种感觉时，身体就会转化为一种情绪，事物移动的地方，这是一种有趣的，你知道，学习的东西。但当你做的时候，你知道这些东西在大脑中的位置，或者大脑在做什么吗？我的意思是，荣格派是相当现象学的，但当他们……而且这些人是医生和工程师，他们建造了这个东西，但你知道，再说一次，我不是医生。我只是试图解释，你知道，一些可能超出我能力范围的事情。
But there's basically like frequencies, like wavelengths that the brain moves at. And none of them are good or bad. You know, just like a lot of the MBTI functions. It's just when they're unconscious or when they're overrepresented, the people are not flexible. So you wear the cap and then they look at what the brain is doing and they're like okay well the the theta wave is too high and i don't know if this is really what the theta wave is but like one of them they're like you're you're thinking reflexively internally all the time you're very self-conscious you're
但基本上有频率，就像大脑移动时的波长。它们没有好坏之分。你知道，就像许多MBTI功能一样。只是当它们处于潜意识中或过度表现时，人们就不灵活了。所以你戴上帽子，然后他们观察大脑在做什么，他们会说，好吧，θ波太高了，我不知道这是否真的是θ波的含义，但就像其中一个，他们会说，你一直在进行反思性的内部思考，你非常自我意识，你
wondering if you're coming off well if things are you're thinking about how you appear and people are like yeah yeah that's exactly what my problem is and they're like well you're doing that 90% of the time you need to do it 10 make room for these other frequencies but a lot of them seem like they have a correlation with typology that what they're doing probably know dario nardi's work and he's certainly been doing actual location of the eight function attitudes and he has, he has this book. I, I think he is trying to get to this for us. But my feeling is that I keep wishing that I had learned my neuroanatomy better than I did.
想知道你表现得好不好，如果事情……你在思考你看起来怎么样，人们会说，是的，是的，那正是我的问题。他们会说，好吧，你90%的时间都在这样做，你需要把它降到10%，为这些其他频率腾出空间。但其中许多似乎与类型学有相关性，他们正在做的事情可能知道达里奥·纳尔迪（Dario Nardi）的工作，他当然一直在对八个功能态度进行实际定位，他有，他有这本书。我，我认为他正在试图为我们实现这一点。但我的感觉是，我一直希望我能比现在更好地学习神经解剖学。
And I feel like as you talk to me, I can almost feel like you know, Moses never got to the promised land. I begin to feel a little like Moses, but even at 83 I'm not afraid to keep learning i think i have some learning to do because i think there is something there i will go back to
我觉得当你和我交谈时，我几乎能感觉到，你知道，摩西从未到达应许之地。我开始感觉有点像摩西，但即使在83岁时，我也不怕继续学习，我想我还有一些东西要学，因为我认为那里确实有些东西。我会回到
something in a dream that young interpreted that you may not know that in 1919 was the first year that young used the term archetype but it was also the year in which Jung published in the Lancet, L-A-N-C-E-T, which is one of the two great scientific medical journals that everyone recognizes. And even then was bad. The other being Nature. If you published in nature or the lancet that means that you have done something for science and so those two those two uh journals are critical well he young published in the lancet that year and what he published was the correlation between in a diagnosis he made on the basis of a dream and a diagnosis that was confirmed,
梦中的某件事，荣格解释过，你可能不知道1919年是荣格使用“原型”这个词的第一年，但那也是荣格在《柳叶刀》（Lancet）上发表文章的一年，L-A-N-C-E-T，这是每个人都认可的两大科学医学期刊之一。即使在当时也很糟糕。另一个是《自然》（Nature）。如果你在《自然》或《柳叶刀》上发表文章，那就意味着你为科学做出了贡献，所以那两本期刊至关重要。好吧，他荣格那一年在《柳叶刀》上发表了文章，他发表的是基于梦境做出的诊断与通过尸检证实的诊断之间的相关性，
and the correlation was what was found at autopsy. The dream was of a patient who dreamt that he saw two ancient elephants, I guess they called them mastodons, I wouldn't tell you was not the word, those very ancient elephants, drowning in a pool of, in a lake of water, some kind of lake. They were drowning in a pool of, in a lake of water, some kind of lake.
相关性就是尸检中发现的结果。那个梦是一位病人梦见他看到两头古老的象，我想他们称之为乳齿象，我不会告诉你那不是那个词，那些非常古老的象，淹没在一个水池里，在一个湖里，某种湖。他们淹没在一个水池里，在一个湖里，某种湖。
They were drowning in a lake. I think I've got the dream right. This whole dream has been discussed in great and meticulous detail by Russell Lockhart, but Jung published it in Lancet because on the basis of the dream Jung said this man has a brain tumor and Lockhart has unlocked how and it's it's a brain tumor that's in the region a certain region of the brain well you have to know how Jung got that interpretation. He was particularly, he was so concerned with being a good doctor.
他们淹没在一个湖里。我想我记对了那个梦。整个梦已经被罗素·洛克哈特（Russell Lockhart）进行了非常细致的讨论，但荣格在《柳叶刀》上发表了它，因为基于这个梦，荣格说这个男人有脑瘤，而洛克哈特已经解开了它是如何……这是一个位于大脑某个区域的脑瘤。好吧，你必须知道荣格是如何得到那个解释的。他特别，他非常关心成为一名好医生。
He really overcompensated and used his introverted sensation, which I think was his eighth function, so skillfully that he was still a legend about how much medicine he knew and when later Jung had imagined didn't have the wording that he later had but he imagined he was a sensation type because he paid so much attention to very precise detail there are two organs called the mammillary bodies which which are have that name and they carry memory for the brain. And Jung knew that the word mammillary body comes from the same word as the Latin word for elephant. So he could imagine that if the patient was having a dream that the elephants, that the mammillary bodies must be drowning in cerebrospinal fluid,
他真的过度补偿并使用了他的内倾感觉，我认为这是他的第八功能，如此熟练，以至于关于他懂多少医学，他仍然是一个传奇。后来荣格想象……没有他后来拥有的措辞，但他想象自己是一个感觉类型，因为他非常关注非常精确的细节。有两个器官被称为乳头体（mammillary bodies），它们有那个名字，它们承载着大脑的记忆。荣格知道“乳头体”这个词来自与拉丁语中“象”相同的词。所以他可以想象，如果病人做梦梦见象，那么乳头体一定淹没在脑脊液中，
and that could only happen if there was some kind of blockage to the flow of cerebrospinal fluid, which therefore would be a tumor. And he made that interpretation, that prediction, and it was published. So there is the best evidence that Jung was willing to think of the archetypal. He always felt dreams were self-portraits of the actual situation in the unconscious, and that would include, in this case, the actual physical situation in the person's brain. So I think that's a very important historical essay, and I advise you to look at it, and if I can find Russell Lockhart's. I googled it after you told me about it last time, and I couldn't find it,
而这只有在脑脊液流动受阻时才会发生，因此那将是一个肿瘤。他做出了那个解释，那个预测，并且它被发表了。所以这是荣格愿意考虑原型层面的最好证据。他一直认为梦是潜意识中实际情况的自画像，这在那种情况下，将包括人脑中的实际物理情况。所以我认为这是一篇非常重要的历史文章，我建议你看看它，如果我能找到罗素·洛克哈特的……我上次你告诉我之后谷歌了一下，但我没找到，
but knowing that it's in The Lancet makes it easier so I can probably find it. I think we should definitely pay attention to the fact that though Jungians have frequently settled for the union mentalis thinking that Jung is the most brilliant way to understand soul experience and try to make it a union of spirit and soul, that that's a lesser conjunction. We really can include the body. And if we do, we will find that in the body of Jung's work, he never really leaves the body out. And I think that if we did nothing else for Jung than to give him full credit for that.
但知道它在《柳叶刀》上让它更容易找到，所以我可能能找到它。我认为我们绝对应该注意这样一个事实：尽管荣格派经常满足于荣格的心理，认为荣格是理解灵魂体验最辉煌的方式，并试图使它成为精神与灵魂的结合，但这是一种较小的结合。我们真的可以包括身体。如果我们这样做，我们会发现，在荣格的作品主体中，他从未真正把身体排除在外。我认为，如果我们为荣格做的仅仅是给予他充分的认可，
Yeah. I think we'd have done something. This is kind of a weirder question, but I've always kind of been curious about what your thoughts would be on this. You know, with the BB model, a lot of it,
是的。我想我们已经做了一些事情。这是一个有点奇怪的问题，但我一直对你的想法感到好奇。你知道，对于BB模型，很大程度上，
what you're doing is taking the BTI type and using it to predict an internal cosmology. You know what somebody's trickster looks like, what's going to show up as a demon so what very beautifully thank you do you think it's possible to run that algorithm backwards like to try and take the typology of like a cosmology of a of a society's mythological system or of a you know maybe a science fiction author fantasy author and then be able to kind of intuit a typology of a culture almost and and some of the things going on with the cultures you know all the time with film and with politics and with with the presentations of cultures i spend a lot
你所做的是采用BTI类型并用它来预测内部宇宙观。你知道某人的捣蛋鬼（trickster）看起来是什么样，什么会表现为恶魔，所以非常漂亮，谢谢。你认为有可能反向运行该算法吗？比如尝试采用某种社会神话系统的宇宙观，或者某种科幻作家、奇幻作家的类型学，然后能够直觉地了解一种文化的类型学，以及文化中一直在发生的一些事情，你知道，电影和政治，以及文化的呈现，我花了很多
of time for instance and i've published about this if If you believe, as I do, that the natural dominant of Chinese culture is introverted intuition, the most gigantic achievements, the Daoist Qing, the I Ching, are obvious examples of a tremendous capacity of introverted intuition. I would have to include I Ching there. And if you've ever experienced Chinese people directly,
时间，例如，我发表过关于这个的文章，如果你像我一样相信中国文化的自然主导是内倾直觉，最巨大的成就，道教的《清》，《易经》，是内倾直觉巨大能力的明显例子。我必须把《易经》包括在内。如果你曾经直接接触过中国人民，
you have such a distorted idea of what China is, especially when we're in a political countertop with China, which I'm very sad about when that happens. I'm not saying that China hasn't participated in it at a political level, but I really don't like, I really think if China and America could get along, they could civilize the rest of the world because they have that potential. But we've got to first civilize our relationship to China, and that's a very difficult thing. And China's with us, too, of course.
你对中国是什么会有如此扭曲的想法，特别是当我们处于与中国的政治对抗中时，我对此感到非常难过。我并不是说中国没有在政治层面上参与其中，但我真的不喜欢，我真的认为如果中国和美国能够和睦相处，他们可以教化世界其他地区，因为他们有那种潜力。但我们必须首先教化我们与中国的关系，这是一件非常困难的事情。当然，中国也和我们在一起。
But the experiment in international communication I've been involved in for the last 21 24 years now I mean it's just proves beyond a shadow of a doubt to me what we can have the Chinese extroverted feeling as it's auxiliary I've met such a welcoming affirmingming group of people, such a fine group of people that I have worked with personally. So if you accept that that's an MBTI INFJ presentation, we have to understand that partly because of the way the West tried to colonize China, starting with the opium wars of the British in the 1850s that sit for the last 175 years,
但我参与的国际交流实验在过去21、24年里，我的意思是，它向我证明了毫无疑问我们可以拥有什么。中国的外倾情感作为辅助，我遇到过一群如此热情、肯定的人，一群我曾亲自合作过的优秀群体。所以如果你接受那是MBTI INFJ的呈现，我们必须理解，部分是因为西方试图殖民中国的方式，从1850年代英国的鸦片战争开始，那持续了过去175年，
really, the problem of China has not only been to keep China for the Chinese and get the colonizing forces out of it. I mean, there are some really pretty awful stories that take place in the late 19th century. And there's even a terrible photo of a young American soldier grinning as he sits on the emperor's throne in China after the Americans have broken into the forbidden city, something we should all be ashamed of.
真的，中国的问题不仅是保持中国人的中国，并将殖民势力赶出去。我的意思是，19世纪末发生了一些非常糟糕的故事。甚至有一张可怕的照片，一名年轻的美国士兵在美国人闯入紫禁城后，坐在中国的皇帝宝座上咧嘴大笑，这是我们所有人都应该感到羞耻的事情。
It's just terrible. But the effort to get China for the Chinese, which was the goal of Sun Yat-sen and then his two sons, Mao Zedong and Chiang Kai-shek. Chiang Kai-shek eventually lost the civil war and he went to Taiwan. And now you have the so-called two Chinas. But everything was to get China for the Chinese.
这太可怕了。但让中国成为中国人的努力，那是孙中山的目标，然后是他的两个儿子，毛泽东和蒋介石。蒋介石最终输掉了内战，他去了台湾。现在你有所谓的两个中国。但一切都是为了让中国成为中国人的中国。
And both of those countries are thriving and successful for Taiwan is not entirely a country for various reasons, but it is thriving. And so is China. They're both thriving. China is now for the Chinese. But there's been this massive overcompensation of the inferior function of extroverted cessation, which is a classic Adlerian, Alfred Adler, overcompensation for a sense of inferiority to prove to everyone that China can be cities as gleaming as American cities. And it's true if you're in Guangzhou,
这两个国家都在蓬勃发展和成功，台湾由于各种原因不完全是一个国家，但它正在蓬勃发展。中国也是。他们都在蓬勃发展。中国现在是属于中国人的。但外倾感觉的劣势功能出现了这种大规模的过度补偿，这是一种经典的阿德勒式（阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒），对自卑感的过度补偿，向所有人证明中国可以拥有像美国城市一样闪闪发光的城市。如果你在广州，这是真的，
it's one of the most beautifully designed modern cities. And it has everything in terms of advanced designers, Seattle, Washington. It's just a very, very beautifully planned, beautifully laid out city now that was once like Hong Kong, a kind of English colonized city. So when you see the overcompensation of extroverted sensation in China
它是设计最精美的现代城市之一。它在高级设计师方面拥有一切，西雅图，华盛顿。它现在是一个规划得非常、非常精美，布局非常精美的城市，曾经像香港一样，是一种英国殖民城市。所以当你看到中国外倾感觉的过度补偿时，
has all the problems of any overcompensation. It's too much pressure on the inferior function and it's not good. But then we look at our country and here we have a natural country that's extroverted thinking with auxiliary introverted sensation. George Washington was the most introverted sensation of our presidents. You know that I often talk about how the battle of Yorktown, he fights all day leading the general. But before he goes to bed, the night he's won the battle of Yorktown and that kind of 18th century thing that starts at dawn
它有任何过度补偿的所有问题。这对劣势功能压力太大，这不好。但随后我们看看我们的国家，在这里我们有一个自然的国家，它是外倾思考，辅助内倾感觉。乔治·华盛顿是我们总统中最内倾感觉的一位。你知道我经常谈论约克镇战役，他整天都在战斗，领导将军。但在他上床睡觉之前，他赢得约克镇战役的那天晚上，那种从黎明开始的18世纪的事情，
and goes all day, you can only imagine what it must have been like to win the battle of Yorktown. Before he goes to bed, he takes out his ledger and carefully records every cannonball and every uniform and every expense made for that day so that he doesn't miss the expenses. He's still accounting for everything. He kept the books. So we once had that kind of, we've only had one president in recent years
整天都在进行，你只能想象赢得约克镇战役是什么感觉。在他上床睡觉之前，他拿出他的账本，仔细记录了那天每一枚炮弹、每一件制服和每一笔开支，这样他就不会错过开支。他仍然在为一切记账。他记账了。所以我们曾经有那种，我们最近几年只有一位总统
that was truly introverted sensation, and that was Eisenhower. And of course he wanted to balance the budget. He said, it's going to be a problem in the future if we don't. And nobody wanted to listen to him. And so we have this auxiliary introverted sensation that we should use, but we don we don't instead we've replaced it
是真正的内倾感觉，那就是艾森豪威尔。当然，他想平衡预算。他说，如果我们不这样做，未来会成为一个问题。没有人想听他的。所以我们有这种辅助内倾感觉，我们应该使用它，但我们没有，我们没有，相反我们已经取代了它，
repeatedly they did it in the end of the 19th century with the robber barons and we're doing it now with the you know the waltz of the billionaires and we make that we it's this And so we constantly use our greedy Saturn extroverted sensation as if it were our auxiliary. And then we have our famous tertiary, poor, eternus extroverted intuition, our Clinton function. And so we have, I'm a Democrat by the way, but I do see the problems. And so we're pathologically extroverted. I'm a Democrat, by the way, but I do see the problems. So we're pathologically extroverted. We're like a manic episode. We're hypomanic, if not frankly manic.
反复地，他们在19世纪末用强盗大亨（robber barons）做到了，我们现在用，你知道，亿万富翁的华尔兹做到了，我们制造了那个，我们……这是……所以我们不断地使用我们贪婪的土星外倾感觉，就好像它是我们的辅助功能一样。然后我们有我们著名的第三功能，可怜的，永恒少年（puer aeternus）外倾直觉，我们的克林顿功能。所以我们有，顺便说一句，我是民主党人，但我确实看到了问题。所以我们是病态地外倾。顺便说一句，我是民主党人，但我确实看到了问题。所以我们是病态地外倾。我们就像一场躁狂发作。我们是轻躁狂，如果不是坦率的躁狂的话。
And, of course, we're irritable. We're angry. And, of course, we have violence because that's what people who get into hypomania and mania get into. Well, like you were describing at the the beginning you going out and buying a new book across town or seeing a new film that's probably pretty helpful to the engine of capitalism if you have everybody doing this i love to spend i love to go shopping and and you know we've when around the time of 9-1-1, someone said that, you know, we've got to prove that we're not going to let them get to us. We've got to shop until we drop.
当然，我们易怒。我们愤怒。当然，我们有暴力，因为这就是陷入轻躁狂和躁狂的人会陷入的境地。嗯，就像你在开头描述的那样，你出去在城里买一本新书或看一部新电影，如果你让每个人都这样做，这对资本主义的引擎可能非常有帮助。我喜欢消费，我喜欢去购物，你知道，在9/11前后，有人说，你知道，我们必须证明我们不会让他们得逞。我们必须购物直到我们倒下。
I remember. Constant conversation about growing the economy as if growth were the... so we really have a lot to learn about the checks and balances within typology itself that if the leading function and this is where isabel briggs myers really contributed to something young wasn't didn't make nearly as clear that he did say the auxiliary function is different in every respect from the dominant, but he didn't seem to mean it. All he seemed to mean was that if the dominant is a rational function, the auxiliary will be an irrational function. He seemed to believe that if you were extroverted, your first three functions were extroverted. If you were introverted,
我记得。关于增长经济的持续对话，就好像增长是……所以我们确实有很多关于类型学内部制衡的知识要学习，如果主导功能——这就是伊莎贝尔·布里格斯·迈尔斯（Isabel Briggs Myers）真正贡献的地方，荣格并没有说得那么清楚——他确实说过辅助功能在各个方面都与主导功能不同，但他似乎并不是那个意思。他似乎只是想说，如果主导功能是理性功能，辅助功能将是非理性功能。他似乎相信，如果你是外倾的，你的前三个功能是外倾的。如果你是内倾的，
your first three functions were introverted, and your compensation came through the inferior function. That's the one that would be of the other attitude. I like the idea of the typology as a system of checks and balances. And that has been so helpful to see. So that when I, so that when I see that in people, I also want to see it in cultures. I would like to see China restore its dominant introverted intuition. And I'd like to see America restore its dominant extroverted thinking and do that. And I'd like to keep its excursions into things like extroverted sensation.
你的前三个功能是内倾的，而你的补偿来自劣势功能。那是属于另一种态度的功能。我喜欢将类型学视为一种制衡系统的想法。这对于观察人们非常有帮助。所以当我，所以当我看到人们身上有这一点时，我也想在文化中看到它。我希望看到中国恢复其主导的内倾直觉。我希望看到美国恢复其主导的外倾思考并做到这一点。我希望保持它对外倾感觉等事物的探索。
I'd like to keep China's excursions into things like extroverted sensation to a more modest place. I think we need to recover our natural typologies and then try to relate to each other that we could do not easy but uh i'm a dreamer but i but i haven't given up well it's an interesting map and you never know who sees that and and you know uses it later did you ever read Lament for the Dead that Sanu Shamdasani and James Hillman have a conversation about the Red Book?
我希望将中国对外倾感觉等事物的探索保持在一个更适度的位置。我认为我们需要恢复我们的自然类型学，然后尝试相互联系，我们可以做到，不容易，但……我是个梦想家，但我……我还没有放弃。嗯，这是一张有趣的地图，你永远不知道谁会看到它，并且，你知道，以后使用它。你读过索努·沙姆达萨尼（Sonu Shamdasani）和詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）关于《红书》（Red Book）的对话《为死者哀歌》（Lament for the Dead）吗？
I've read some of it, and I haven't read every word of it. What did you find in it that you found interesting? Well, they kind of hit on an ethics in Jung that's not ever really laid out in what he writes, but I think they are onto something that the unlived life of the parent is an obstacle, but really it's the unlived life of all of the dead. It's our job to go past the places where humanity hasn't gone yet. And the unlived life of our culture is something that we feel. What I feel is that what I got from Sonu I had my own conversation with Sonu which you may not have seen
我读过一些，我没有读过每一个字。你在其中发现了什么你觉得有趣的东西？嗯，他们触及了荣格的一种伦理，这在他写的任何东西中都没有真正阐述过，但我认为他们发现了一些东西，父母未竟的生活是一个障碍，但实际上是所有死者未竟的生活。我们的工作是超越人类尚未去过的地方。我们文化中未竟的生活是我们所感受到的。我的感受是，我从索努那里得到的东西，我曾与索努进行过我自己的对话，你可能没见过，
which was published in Psychological Perspectives I'd be happy to share we had a dialogue about the red book that was published before the Lament of the Dead and I take very seriously Jung's idea that what we owe the dead is to take
发表在《心理学视角》（Psychological Perspectives）上，我很乐意分享，我们在《为死者哀歌》出版之前就《红书》进行了一次对话，我非常认真地对待荣格的观点，即我们欠死者的是去承担
up the projects they left unfinished yeah yeah let's tell you that i have felt i've tried to do that i actually felt that young site typology was an unfinished project forward all of us to move forward and I feel that I've followed I've actually taken up that project rather than trying to replace it with my own I see myself as
他们未完成的项目。是的，是的，告诉你，我感觉我已经尝试那样做了。我实际上觉得荣格的类型学是一个未完成的项目，供我们所有人向前推进，我觉得我已经跟随……我实际上已经承担了那个项目，而不是试图用我自己的项目来取代它。我把自己看作是
adding and extending and trying to complete something that I felt that he absolutely didn't quite finish that's how I see it I don't mean to be arrogant about that,
添加和扩展，并试图完成一些我觉得他绝对没有完全完成的事情。我就是这样看的。我并不是想对此表现得傲慢，
but I also feel with my mother and my father, I've had to carry projects they started. And so I feel that that gets into what my colleague, who grew up as an African-American man in Jackson, Mississippi, and is now a Jungian analyst, and was a past president, like myself, of the C.G. Jung Institute of San Francisco, and I know his work very well. He speaks of phantom narratives, of course, in literature and by another African-American author, Tony Morrison. Beloved is a perfect example of phantom and complex. It's based on a true story of a woman who, while a slave, killed her babies because she did not want them to have to grow up as slaves.
但我也觉得对于我的母亲和父亲，我不得不承担他们开始的项目。所以我觉得这涉及到了我的同事，他作为一名非裔美国男性在密西西比州杰克逊长大，现在是一名荣格分析师，并且像我一样是旧金山C.G.荣格研究所的前任所长，我非常了解他的工作。他当然在文学作品中谈到了幻影叙事，以及另一位非裔美国作家托妮·莫里森（Toni Morrison）。《宠儿》（Beloved）是幻影和情结的完美例子。它基于一个真实的故事，一个女人在奴隶制期间杀死了她的孩子，因为她不想让他们不得不作为奴隶长大。
But then what happens is that she becomes, in Toni Morrison's novel, a woman living during the Reconstruction era who discovers that one of the children returns as a reven but returns as a phantom, she says of her that it's my best thing. means is that the African American would have to not simply repress and forget the memory of slavery, but take it in as something to work with, take that that fate that horrible fate and something to work with as indeed our culture has to take that in bigger culture has to take that in as well but for the idea of african americans taking that on and if the african-american is willing to take that on? Why in the world can't America take on that phantomatic narrative? Taking phantomatic narratives, taking on what
但后来发生的事情是，在托妮·莫里森的小说中，她成为了一名生活在重建时代的女性，她发现其中一个孩子作为幽灵回来了，但作为幻影回来了，她说关于她的是“我最好的东西”。意思是，非裔美国人将不得不不仅仅是压抑和忘记奴隶制的记忆，而是将其作为可以利用的东西吸收，将那种命运，那种可怕的命运，作为确实可以利用的东西，正如我们的文化必须吸收它一样，更大的文化也必须吸收它。但对于非裔美国人承担这一点的想法，如果非裔美国人愿意承担这一点？为什么美国不能承担那种幻影叙事？承担幻影叙事，承担
we owe the dead is to stay with the problem they left unsolved and do what we can to solve it. And so I feel like in every... So in that sense, working on the inner is always going to take us to an unsolved psychological problem of our entire culture. You're kind of going through the self, through the parent,
我们欠死者的是留在他们留下的未解决的问题中，并尽我们所能去解决它。所以我感觉在每一个……所以从这个意义上说，致力于内在总是会把我们带到我们整个文化的一个未解决的心理问题上。你有点通过自我，通过父母，
to the culture to find the self. And it's sort of like what is called karma in the West. It's sort of what we have to do. Jung, and I do say all this in my preface to Jung's aspect of the masculine, where he took on his father's unsolved problem of Christian faith. He's a Christian minister who lost his faith just around the same time that Nietzsche was saying God was dead. Nietzsche, the son of a Christian minister. And Jung takes on the whole question of faith. He knew more about the history of faith than most people know.
到文化去寻找自我。这有点像西方所说的业力（karma）。这有点像我们必须做的事情。荣格，我确实在我的《荣格的男性面向》（Jung's aspect of the masculine）序言中说了所有这些，在那里他承担了他父亲未解决的基督教信仰问题。他是一位基督教牧师，在尼采说上帝已死的同时失去了信仰。尼采，一位基督教牧师的儿子。荣格承担了整个信仰问题。他比大多数人更了解信仰的历史。
One of the people that taught for a living, a Dutch scholar, Gilles, G-I-L-L-E-S Quispel, Q-U-I-S-P-E-L told me that he's taught in a university in Holland and his job was to be give
其中一位以教学为生的人，一位荷兰学者，吉尔斯（Gilles Quispel），Q-U-I-S-P-E-L，告诉我，他在荷兰的一所大学教书，他的工作是给
people PhDs in the history of the church fathers which is called in the Christian church, patristics. And he said that Jung was better read in patristics than any graduate student that he ever had. That was Jung's work on his father's faith problem, to study all the Christian father's faith. Jungian psychology, I mean, a lot of that could be seen as this thing to give his problem to study all the Christian father's faith. So that. Yungi in psychology. I mean, a lot of,
人们提供教会教父历史的博士学位，这在基督教教会中被称为教父学（patristics）。他说，荣格在教父学方面的阅读量比他教过的任何研究生都要多。那是荣格在他父亲的信仰问题上的工作，去研究所有基督教教父的信仰。荣格心理学，我的意思是，很多都可以被视为这种东西，去研究所有基督教教父的信仰。所以那个。荣格心理学。我的意思是，很多，
a lot of that could be seen as this thing to give his father to try and help him. Have faith in a different way. And give him enough of the history of faith and the context of faith within the history of world religions. So that. Of course, he would be confused. Of course, you would need a bigger picture. And I, so that, of course, you would be confused.
很多都可以被视为这种东西，去给他的父亲，去尝试帮助他。以不同的方式拥有信仰。并给他足够的信仰历史和世界宗教历史中的信仰背景。所以那个。当然，他会感到困惑。当然，你需要一个更大的图景。而我，所以那个，当然，你会感到困惑。
Of course, you would need a bigger picture. And so in that sense, what a wonderful thing to have done, just like what a wonderful thing for me to go back to China and do something about being a pig. I mean, why not? I mean, in other words, why not? And how good it makes you feel. The amazing thing is, I mean, in other words, why not? And how good it makes you feel. The amazing thing is, I mean, Toni Morrison set herself free
当然，你需要一个更大的图景。所以从这个意义上说，做这件事是一件多么美妙的事情，就像我回到中国并做一些关于成为一只猪的事情一样。我的意思是，为什么不呢？我的意思是，换句话说，为什么不呢？而且它让你感觉多好。令人惊奇的事情是，我的意思是，换句话说，为什么不呢？而且它让你感觉多好。令人惊奇的事情是，我的意思是，托妮·莫里森通过写作《宠儿》和其他书让自己自由了，
by writing Beloved and other books, and what a wonderful achievement. So that's the kind of thing that makes me feel like. So it often will turn out to be a type of consciousness that didn't get a chance to tell its whole story. My ideas of the consciousnesses. It's not finished, and it's not always containable to one life. You have to listen to... What I have to stop is that each consciousness has its own story arc.
这是一个多么美妙的成就。所以这就是那种让我感觉……所以它通常会变成一种没有机会讲述其完整故事的意识类型。我对意识的想法。它没有完成，而且并不总是能包含在一个生命中。你必须倾听……我必须停止的是，每种意识都有其自己的故事弧。
My extroverted intuition has the story arc of entertaining. If I'm anything, I'm entertaining when I lecture, and I'm also getting people to entertain ideas. So it starts with entertaining an interesting set of ideas but then it moves toward envisioning and now we're very much there right now because i'm envisioning with you and you are with me thank you what we can do with this but finally it's going even beyond that at the level of the move from the persona of it to the ego of it. But now I want to get to the self of it, meaning the purpose of it.
我的外倾直觉有娱乐的故事弧。如果我有什么的话，我在讲课时是娱乐性的，我也在让人们娱乐想法。所以它始于娱乐一系列有趣的想法，但随后它转向设想，现在我们非常处于那个阶段，因为我正在和你一起设想，而你和我在一起，谢谢，我们可以用这个做什么，但最终它甚至超越了这一点，在从它的人格（persona）到它的自我（ego）的层面。但现在我想谈谈它的自性（self），意味着它的目的。
It's enabling. I want what Isabel Riggs Myers wants. I want the world to understand each other better. So I can't leave her out. And I want what Jung wanted, which is to take up the unsolved problems of the dead, complete the Christian project, the psychological project. In other words, it's very important. And it's good for us to do that, and it probably does good for others as well.
它是赋能的。我想要伊莎贝尔·布里格斯·迈尔斯想要的东西。我希望世界能更好地相互理解。所以我不能把她排除在外。我想要荣格想要的东西，那就是承担死者未解决的问题，完成基督教项目，心理学项目。换句话说，这非常重要。这对我们来说是好事，而且它可能对其他人也有好处。
That's what it seems like to me. Well, I think that's why the lament or the dead conversation that they had was interesting to me because I always liked depth psychology and feel like it's a great map. But I also am very interested in the directly experiential kinds of therapy coming out now that are that are more shamanistic i mean brain spotting is that way internal family systems is that way i mean they have a gestalt kind of component to them and um and you know hillman james hillman it was a brilliant guy and also a very good analyst by all accounts, but kind of got grandiose or off in places towards the end of his life. And in the Lament for the Dead book, he's talking and I could kind of feel like, okay, I think that what I'm trying to do is finish your project of archetypal psychology that you never quite figured out a technique for or you never you know and you know i've there was an energy there that just was
这就是我看起来的样子。嗯，我认为这就是为什么他们进行的关于死者的哀歌对话对我来说很有趣，因为我一直喜欢深度心理学，觉得它是一张很棒的地图。但我也非常感兴趣现在出现的直接体验式的治疗，它们更具萨满色彩，我的意思是脑点定位是那样，内在家庭系统（Internal Family Systems）是那样，我的意思是它们有一种格式塔（gestalt）的成分，嗯，你知道希尔曼，詹姆斯·希尔曼，他是一个聪明的人，也是一位非常好的分析师，据所有人的说法，但在他生命的尽头，在某些地方变得宏大或偏离了。在《为死者哀歌》这本书中，他在谈话，我能感觉到，好吧，我想我正在尝试做的是完成你从未真正找到技术的原型心理学项目，或者你从未……你知道，我有一种能量在那里，只是
was interesting you know um i don't know well yes i think introverted feeling introverted intuition cannot safely leave out an extroverted feeling and and and and you don't obviously so well the intuitive feeler types you know they're a lot of the more effective people have that function but when they go bad they go really bad you know it's like the same personality or the same typology of jesus is also the typology of Hitler, you know? And you look at, you look at the people who, you know, 2020 brought all of these personalities that are on YouTube and whatever, and, you know, talking to younger people and saying all this awful stuff and you look in
很有趣，你知道，嗯，我不知道，嗯，是的，我认为内倾感觉，内倾直觉不能安全地排除外倾情感，而且，而且，而且你显然没有，所以，嗯，直觉感觉类型，你知道，很多更有效的人都有那个功能，但当他们变坏时，他们真的变坏了，你知道，这就像耶稣的相同人格或相同类型学也是希特勒的类型学，你知道吗？你看看，你看看那些，你知道，2020年带来了所有这些在YouTube上和无论什么地方的人格，而且，你知道，与年轻人交谈并说所有这些可怕的事情，你看看
their past, almost every one of those guys is a failed comedian, you know? They, you know, they all have that intuitive felt, you know, thing that does come from a pain in childhood that gives you some kind of voice and perspective but if you don't master it i mean it really can eat you alive you don't you don't you don't dare leave that live out the body outside of the body we have to stop now because of time but uh for me i have to call coming in at noon, so I'm going to have to take. Thank you so much. I really appreciate your time. Thank you for your presence, Joel. You've been very open to letting me talk, and I got a little hint of where you're coming from.
他们的过去，几乎每一个那些家伙都是失败的喜剧演员，你知道吗？他们，你知道，他们都有那种直觉感觉，你知道，确实来自童年的痛苦，给你某种声音和视角，但如果你不掌握它，我的意思是它真的可以把你活活吃掉，你不要，你不要，你不要敢把那个活生生的身体排除在身体之外。我们现在必须因为时间而停止，但呃，对我来说，我必须在中午有电话进来，所以我必须去。非常感谢。我真的很感激你的时间。谢谢你的出席，乔尔。你一直非常开放地让我说话，我得到了一点你来自哪里的暗示。
I want to share with you the Chinese notion of completion. There's an image of the integrity of integrity in the Qing that I love so much. And I wrote about this, I haven't ever published this paper, it's actually a talk that I'm planning to publish. But there are three elements to the image of integrity. And one is sincerity. One is limitation, a sense of limits, and that's important when you mention grandiosity, which
我想和你分享中国关于完成的概念。在《清》中有一个关于完整性的完整性的形象，我非常喜欢。我写过这个，我从来没有发表过这篇论文，它实际上是我计划发表的一次演讲。但完整性的形象有三个要素。一个是真诚。一个是限制，一种限制感，当你提到宏大时，这很重要，
gets to all of us from time to time. And then finally, completion. What Leosa did in completing the projects is one way not to get inflated and there's a sincerity in it and there's a sense of limitation that each life has its limitation but there's also what can be done and what we can do is to complete. So America is an experiment in democracy
这不时会影响我们所有人。然后最后，完成。利奥萨（Leosa）在完成项目方面所做的是一种不膨胀的方式，其中有一种真诚，有一种限制感，即每个生命都有其限制，但也有可以做的事情，我们可以做的是完成。所以美国是一个民主的实验，
that is presently trying to complete itself. And we have to let that completion take place. And that's the task of our lifetime. Well, we also have our typology and our psychology. We have to complete the task of bringing the body and the spirit and the soul together in an adequate theory and practice. And then a technique to apply the theory. Here we are together, and you've taken my work and added it to yours. That makes me very happy.
目前正试图完成自己。我们必须让那种完成发生。这就是我们一生的任务。嗯，我们也有我们的类型学和我们的心理学。我们必须完成将身体、精神和灵魂结合在一个充分的理论和实践中的任务。然后是一种应用该理论的技术。我们在这里在一起，你已经采用了我的工作并将其添加到你的工作中。这让我非常高兴。
Well, thank you so much for this, John. I really appreciate it. It's been wonderful and um i'll let you go and um i hope that this brings some new people to your work and um you've got some great books and some great books mark hunsinger you know wrote about you with you and um it's it's exciting thank you thank you for your life thank you wow thank you you're welcome you're welcome have You're very welcome. Have a good one.
嗯，非常感谢你，约翰。我真的很感激。这太棒了，嗯，我会让你走，嗯，我希望这能为你的工作带来一些新的人，嗯，你有一些很棒的书，还有一些很棒的书，马克·亨辛格（Mark Hunsinger）你知道，和你一起写了关于你的书，嗯，这很令人兴奋，谢谢，谢谢你的生活，谢谢，哇，谢谢，不客气，不客气，祝你
Bye. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不客气。祝你过得愉快。再见。保重。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。